Hallo, Wolfgang. Wie bist du zufrieden mit unserem Bundeskanzler?
Inzwischen würde ich sagen, dann ein bisschen mehr Strongmen könnte es schon sein.
Das ist ein interessanter Einstieg, denn wir haben uns eben ganz kurz darüber verständigt, dass wir das Buch eigentlich gar nicht so richtig gut finden. Und diese Frage, die du jetzt so ad hoc aufgeworfen hast, darf man sich ein bisschen mehr Strongmen wünschen von seinem Bundeskanzler?
Ja, ich würde das aber gleich einschränken wollen. Also nicht in dem Sinne der Strongmen, die wir gleich vorgestellt bekommen, sondern tatsächlich muss es ja auch die Aufgabe eines Bundeskanzlers sein, jetzt, wo wir in einer Rezession sind und diese sich verschärfen wird, entsprechend aufzutreten und auch das große Rad zu drehen. Und was wir jetzt eigentlich erlebt haben, ist, dass drei Entlastungspakete gekommen sind, die jedes Mal groß angekündigt werden. Und man dann aber ganz viele Details bekommt und sagt, das ist eigentlich ganz gut, da hat sich ein bisschen was verbessert. Aber das, was eigentlich nötig wäre angesichts der Krise, in der wir sind und in die wir noch schlittern werden, ist es viel, viel zu wenig. Und man muss dann auch mal ein bisschen überlegen, in welche Richtung will man jetzt gehen. Also wir machen jetzt diese Sanktionspolitik, die kostet uns sehr viel. Wir wissen nicht genau, wie schlimm sie Russland dann wirklich auf Dauer treffen wird. Aber wenn man jetzt sich wirklich dazu entscheidet, das genauso weiterzuführen, dann muss man auch ein Gegenangebot schaffen. Dann kann man nicht sagen, und die anderen müssen jetzt sehen, wie ihr zurechtkommt. Und hin und wieder werfen wir noch ein paar Tropfen auf heiße Steine. Und das passiert aber jetzt gerade. Und da bin ich doch sehr enttäuscht, denn wir hatten den Bundeskanzler der Zeitenwende, der groß auftrumpfte im Bundestag, der sich sehr souverän schlug mit amerikanischen Journalisten. Und der jetzt aber sich da so wegduckt, auch von Habeck hört man zunehmend nur noch Defensives. Und das ist zu wenig. Und ich bin, was das anbelangt, sehr für Stärke. Aber nicht in dem Sinne, wir regieren jetzt einfach mit harter Hand durch, also mit der eisernen Faust, sondern eigentlich müsste man jetzt mal schauen, wie kann man dann regieren und auch das große Rad drehen und dann ein Strongman sein in einem anderen Sinne. Denn das wäre ja tatsächlich das, was auch den ganzen Strongman auf der Welt ein bisschen den Wind aus den Segel nehmen würde. Wenn man sieht, man kann schon auch sehr souverän auftreten und selbstbewusst und dann aber eine ganz andere Richtung gehen. Man muss nicht gleich sagen, jeder soll mal mit Waffen Drogenhändler erschießen gehen.
Und ich möchte gern da anknüpfen auf dieser Ebene der Diskussion, die uns das Buch leider nicht bietet. Deswegen schieben wir das kurz auf. Denn was ich mir versprochen habe von so Diskussionen oder die Welt der Autokraten, wie es auf Deutsch heißt, ist ja eigentlich eine Diskussion darüber, was ist dieser neue Autokratismus, der, das wird ja im Buch gesagt, sehr viel mit den neuen Medienmöglichkeiten zu tun hat. Und ich dachte auch so ein bisschen, und deswegen wirklich sehr gut, dass du eben dieses mit Olaf Scholz ein bisschen erwünscht, man sich ja doch. Ich hätte ja gedacht, dass man nach Donald Trump lernt, dass wir in dieser Medienwelt leben, dass sie einfach ist, wie sie ist. So, dass sie ist, wie sie ist, hat man ja gesehen, dass Olaf Scholz, wie viele Probleme er hatte, um niemand streitet ab, dass er hart gegen Antisemitismus kämpft und trotzdem hat er wegen dieser Abwehrssituation, nur wegen dieser Momenthaftigkeit so viele Probleme plötzlich, musste so ewig nacharbeiten. So, was hätte man von Trump lernen können, wenn man als grüner Wirtschaftsminister in Deutschland Verantwortung übernimmt? Ist man in einer Koalition, beispielsweise mit der FDP, muss einen das besonders kümmern oder darf man nicht einfach auf einer grünen Bühne vor grünem Publikum, auch als grüner Wirtschaftsminister, Verantwortung für ganz Deutschland, einfach mal sagen, was man sich wirklich wünscht und das auch populistisch durchdrücken? Die man einfach sagt, hört mal zu, liebe Leute, ich weiß, die da drüben machen irgendwas mit Schuldenbremse. Jetzt kläre ich euch kurz auf, die wollen damit Renditen privatisieren, sobald der Staat irgendwie einen Eigentumstitel erhält, sind die da außen vor, das mögen die nicht. Okay, Haken dran, jetzt zu unserer Sicht. Japan ist mit 200 irgendwas Prozent verschuldet, Amerika ist mit 100 irgendwas Prozent verschuldet, wenn man sich Europa anguckt, 68 Prozent oder so was. Wir haben also noch Spielraum. Ungefähr 40, 50, 60 Prozent. Es spricht nichts dagegen, dass sich Europa auch mit 130 Prozent des europäischen Bips verschuldet. So, diese angenommenen 40, 50 Prozent sind in Billionen Werte übertragen. Keine Ahnung. Ich kann es noch Pi mal Daumen machen, aber das gehört zum Populismus dazu. Vielleicht fünf, vielleicht sechs Billionen Euro. Europa hat die Hoheit über diesen Euro. Wir brauchen nur parlamentarische Entscheidungen. Zack, stünden sie zur Verfügung. Warum steht niemand auf der Bühne und ordert das einfach?
Spezifisch eingesetzt für die Dinge, wo man sie braucht. Also es geht ja nicht darum, jetzt noch eine Vermögenspreisinflation zu beschleunigen.
Genau. Und dann kann man da einen Haken dran machen und sagen, so, an Geld mangelt es nicht.
Wie beim Sondervermögen.
Zum Beispiel, genau, diese Sondervermögen für die Bundeswehr, die Zeitenwende, das konnte man einfach im Bundestag verkünden, Alarm gejubelt, die CDU hat Rippe gemacht.
Und das hat auch keine Auswirkung auf die Inflation. Also die hätten auch 500 Milliarden Euro im Preis setzen können. Das hat ja keinen Inflationseffekt, sondern einen Inflationsbremseneneffekt hätte, wenn man diese 4, 5, 6 Billionen nehmen würde und würde sagen, ja und damit werden jetzt all die Preise, die so steigen, also zum Beispiel Energiepreise, Verkehr, das wird alles damit abgefedert und zugleich wird transformiert in die richtige Richtung. Und dann kommen wir auch wirklich los und zwar auch von den anderen Autokraten. Denn es wird ja nicht so sein, dass wir jetzt einmal mit Putin blöd gelegen haben und die anderen Autokraten, mit denen wir jetzt zusammenarbeiten, da wird alles sauber sein. Da können wir ja schon in drei Jahren den nächsten Konflikt sehen, dass man sagt, ja und jetzt, obwohl die Menschenrechtsverletzungen, obwohl die da irgendwo einmarschiert sind, wollt ihr trotzdem, dann geht dasselbe ja wieder von vorn los.
Genau, wir tauschen jetzt gerade in unserer Politik eine Abhängigkeit von Autokraten gegen andere aus, Katar und so weiter. Und was ich wirklich schockierend finde, ist, dass in diesem Entlastungspaket einfach drinsteht, ja den Klimawandel schieben wir jetzt mal auf. Also die ganzen CO2-Bepreisungen, die werden mal nach hinten geschoben, wo ich mir denke, nee, wenn man eine grüne Regierung hat, und ja sie ist nicht komplett grün, aber sie ist in Teilen grün, und zwar vor allem in der relevanten Funktion Wirtschaftspolitik zu machen, dann kann es gar nicht möglich sein, weil dann könnten auch CDU und FDP regieren, dass man sagt, die CO2-Bepreisung schieben wir auf. Denn wir können, wie wir feststellen, mit Putin nicht verhandeln. Wir können mit dem Klima aber auch nicht verhandeln. Beides drückt. Und dass wir uns jetzt sagen, okay, dann akzeptieren wir irgendwie, was Putin mit uns Böses macht und verschieben diese Last sozusagen in das, was uns dann das Klima demnächst reindrückt. Das ist total Banane. Das macht überhaupt gar keinen Sinn, das so zu organisieren. Vor allem nicht, wenn es an Geld nicht mangelt, sondern wirklich nur Verteilungs- und Organisationsfragen sind. Wenn Geld also wirklich ein Medium ist, um Sachen zu organisieren. Und wir ja feststellen, ganz schön viele, machen gerade ganz schön viel Gewinn. Warum? Ach so, weil die Solar- und Windbranche gar nicht so viel Aufwand hat für die Energie, die sie liefert, sondern nur weil die Gaspreise hoch sind. Und dadurch dieser Preis für die anderen erneuerbaren Energien eben mit in die Höhe gepresst, geschleift, mitgezogen wird. Machen wir noch weniger davon, also Investitionen in diese Richtung. Weil die Reisfindung so bescheuert ist, aufgrund unserer Entscheidung, dass wir den Markt zu organisieren, das ergibt alles überhaupt keinen Sinn. Und da wünsche ich mir Strongman-Politik. Und jetzt ist ja die Frage, wenn wir feststellen, dass Donald Trump auch einen Präsidenten spielt und sogar anderen Präsidenten, von denen er weiß, die heißen eigentlich Präsidenten, aber wie eben im Clip gehört oder von... Genau, ich nenne ihn einfach König. Wir haben auch schon häufiger über die Spielkönige gesprochen, das Prinzip des Spielkönigs. Man fängt erst mal an, einen König zu wählen. Und dann tut man einfach so, als wäre das ein König. So wie Georg Simmel vor 100 Jahren schrieb, in Paris wählen die Bettler einen König. Und da gibt es halt einen König. Die haben dann einfach eine Hierarchie gegründet. Die sind zwar alle mittellos, aber einer wird halt als König angesehen. Und der wird dann aber irgendwann wirklich König. Also der kommt aus der Spielposition heraus in die richtige Rolle. Und wir wissen noch, in dieser medialen Welt... Zum Beispiel.
Der trainiert jemand, ein König zu werden.
Genau. Wie muss ich König in der medialen Welt sein? So und jetzt haben wir nicht nur das Radio, wo im Krieg eine Ansage gemacht werden muss, sondern wir haben jetzt diese durch und durch medialisierte Welt, wo wir ein... Also ich habe diesen Clip noch nicht gesehen, aber bei Maischberger war gestern Robert Habeck und hat sich da wieder in die Nesseln gesetzt, weil er wieder und so weiter. Und da denke ich mir wieder, warum spielst du uns nicht einfach den Wirtschaftsminister vor, den du gerne sein würdest? Und ja, du bist ein Grüner. Warum spielst du uns nicht den grünen Wirtschaftsminister vor, wie du es gerne sein würdest? Warum?
Es ist auch eine unbegründete Angst. Also mein Eindruck ist, und auch wenn ich, egal mit wem ich spreche, es hat sich da ganz viel getan. Also ich glaube, vor zehn Jahren wäre das diskursiv noch so gewesen, dass man gesagt hätte, ja, ja, die Grünen, die kosten uns jetzt das ganze Geld und mit ihren ganzen grünen Klimawandelsachen, so das brauchen wir alles nicht. Das ist jetzt so teuer für uns. Hin und wieder versuchen das noch so Leute wie Fleischhauer im Fokus oder sowas, kann man noch in der Welt lesen. Aber das ist nicht der breite Diskurs gerade. Das ist nicht so, dass die Leute sagen, nee, Klimawandel, das ist uns jetzt alles gerade zu teuer. Man unterhält sich mit Leuten, die sagen, ja, ich habe jetzt auch überlegt, soll ich eigentlich noch ein Gartengemüse anbauen? Wie viel Wasser gieße ich da eigentlich drauf, um da ein bisschen was zu haben? Das heißt, ein Bewusstsein ist, dadurch, dass der Klimawandel vor der Tür ist, direkt jetzt auch ein Gewandeltes. Und damit, glaube ich, würde eine Ansprache, als hier ist ein grüner Wirtschaftsminister, und ich bin wirklich ein grüner Wirtschaftsminister, wahrscheinlich einen enormen Erfolg bedeuten, was zu Kaychwieder bedeutet, denn erst einmal kann man sagen, ja, aber das sind ja noch die Machtkonstellationen. Ja, aber Politiker können ja immer nur auf das reagieren, was stimmungsmäßig so vorfindlich ist. Und das ist ja bei Lindner auch zu spüren in Teilen dann. Und das heißt, wenn Habeck als starker grüner Wirtschaftsminister auftritt, wird Lindner sein, liebe Freunde, ich rette die Welt, indem ich die Schuldenbremse einhalte, das wird nicht mehr ziehen.
Genau, es fehlt hier einfach an Aufklärung, die man nachvollziehen kann. Und die ist eigentlich nicht so schwer. Ich verstehe das alles nicht. Ich meine, wir haben jetzt, du hast diesen Populismus gegen die Grünen angesprochen, fünf Mark für einen Liter Benzin. Das Benzin kostet jetzt fünf Mark. Wer hat denn regiert die letzten 16 Jahre? Haben die Grünen das hervorgerufen, dieses Problem erschaffen? Nein, die können es aber jetzt lösen. Die SPD hat es so ein bisschen geschafft, die roten Sockenkampagnen abzuschütteln. Die Grünen müssen sich da jetzt auch einfach mal befreien. Die sollen jetzt einfach mal ihr Bürgergeld so erfinden, dass sie dieses ganze Hartz-IV-Agenda 2010 usw., dass sie sich davon freimachen. Gerhard Schröder hat sich so weit abgeschossen. Diese Art von Neustart, dass man jetzt so tacheles redet, so Strongman-mäßig, dass man sich ein bisschen –ich habe das ja auch schon vor Jahren da in der Bundespressekonferenz mal sozusagen den Politikern empfohlen, sich mit den Influencern zu beschäftigen, nicht inhaltlich, sondern weil sie einfach Erfolg haben. Man lernt auf den Journalistenschulen alles, außer wie man Publikum aufbaut. So, und das Gleiche gilt ja für die Politiker auch. Sie müssen sich jetzt einfach mal hinsetzen, sich die Autokraten anschauen und sich fragen, wie geht das, wie kann man so ganze Länder sich unterwerfen und dann nur versuchen, methodisch daraus etwas herauszuziehen, was sie vielleicht inspiriert. Und es klingt so ein bisschen, wie soll man sagen?
Werdet jetzt auch Populisten?
Ja, genau.
Das ist damit nicht gemeint.
Genau, die Welt ist ja, wie sie ist. Die mediale Welt ist, wie die mediale Welt eben ist.
Und es ist ja tatsächlich so, dass wir gerade schwach regiert werden, was die wirtschaftlichen Dinge anbelangt. Also ich wundere mich auch, dass da von wirtschaftlicher Seite so wenig Druck gerade entsteht, dass die sagen, also so kann es nicht weitergehen. Wir müssen jetzt aber richtig mal durchgreifen. Denn es ist ja so, wenn man jetzt die Leute arm macht, indem man sie nicht entsprechend unterstützt, indem man da Studenten jetzt eine Einmalzahlung von 200 Euro gibt. Das verpufft ja alles so. Damit sinkt ja die Kaufkraft. Das heißt, die Unternehmen werden bald Probleme haben, diese Produkte zu verkaufen, weil einfach nicht genügend Geld da ist bei den Leuten im Portemonnaie. Das heißt, das ist ja auch für die Industrie, sage ich mal, keine rosige Aussicht, sondern volle Portemonnaies sind schon generell besser, wenn man Wirtschaftswachstum zum Beispiel will oder selbst als Unternehmen einfach nur wachsen möchte. Und da wundert mich, dass da noch so wenig kommt. Aber was man begreifen muss, ist, dass dieses nur zaudern, hadern und wir wollen da noch mal kleine Stücke machen und dass man auch jetzt schon drei Entlastungspakete hat. Statt mal ein großes zu machen. Wahrscheinlich kommen auch noch vier, fünf, sechs. Wir werden sie durchzählen noch. Aber es ist damit natürlich eine hohe Attraktivität gegeben, die allein performativ hergestellt wird. Aber das ist ja mal legal. Wenn jemand auftritt und sagt, so ich nehme die Sache jetzt mal in die Hand. Ob der das dann wirklich kann. Und was da dann eigentlich in den administrativen Bereichen geschieht. Ob die dann auch sagen, gut, da hat er mal wieder Scheiße geredet. Wir werden das aber schon irgendwie machen. Das sei mal dahingestellt. Aber derjenige ist dann vielleicht schon gewählt. Und ich glaube, dass man das als großen Augenblick erkennen muss, dass Macron das noch mal geschafft hat, gewählt zu werden. Und dass Olaf Scholz es geschafft hat, also quasi als Merkel-Fortsetzung in dem Sinne, dass er nicht der große Charismatiker ist. Dass man jetzt aber noch mal einmal schaut, wie könnte die Politik sich so sehr rüsten, indem sie einfach Gutes tut für die Menschen, dass man sagen kann, naja, gut, Populismus oder so, ist ja alles gut und schön. Aber das kann uns ja gar nicht betreffen hier. Denn die Leute sind ja zufrieden mit diesem anderen Politikstil.
Ja, wir haben die FDP, die ein Finanzminister ins Amt schickt, der in seiner Antrittsrede sagt, ich bin hier Chef eines Ermöglichungsministeriums. Und ein halbes Jahr später hören wir nur noch, ja, wir können uns im Bundeshaushalt Spielräume erarbeiten, aber ohne mehr Steuern und ohne Schuldengeldzuflüsse, sondern einfach nur durch interne Verschiebung, wo man sich denkt, nee, hier wird gerade nicht in der Welt intern verschoben, sondern hier findet Revolution statt und bitte mach es da auch. Meine sanfte Idee wäre zu sagen, wir machen nochmal einen Sonderhaushalt im Sinne von ein Jahr extra Haushalt. Also wir nehmen nicht den 2022 Haushalt und kleben nochmal 15 Prozent, also 60 Milliarden, dran, sondern wir erfinden jetzt einfach ein Jahr. Es ist virtuelle Politik. Wir stellen jetzt nochmal ein Bundeshaushalt-Jahr extra zur Verfügung, 400 Milliarden. Auf die Hälfte kann man sich bewerben. Die andere Hälfte wird für all das gemacht, wo jetzt Geld gebraucht ist, wo man einfach wirklich mal Sachen ermöglichen kann. Und es ist einfach absurd, wie es läuft. Aber gut, damit können wir ins Buch einsteigen.
Ja, die starken Männer.
Das Vorwort ist, glaube ich, ganz entscheidend. Du hast es ja schon angesprochen beim letzten Mal, denn das Buch war fertig, bevor Putin in den Krieg zog. Also bot es sich an nochmal.
Ja, und Rachmann diagnostizierte schon oder prognostizierte, das wird noch viel Leid in die Welt bringen, in diese Strongman-Politik. Und er hat ganz schnell dann Recht behalten damit. Und dann in diesem Buch mit dem auseinander, was eigentlich jetzt gerade der Fall ist oder beziehungsweise in den letzten zehn Jahren passiert ist. Und er sagt dann auch in den Vereinten Nationen stimmten 141 von 193 Staaten für die Verurteilung der russischen Invasion. Allerdings enthielten sich China und Indien die beiden bevölkerungsreichsten Länder der Welt. Die Russen konnten sich damit trösten, dass die Staaten, die sich entweder enthielten oder Russland unterstützten, zusammengenommen für die Mehrheit der Weltbevölkerung standen.
Und er macht einen anderen interessanten Hinweis. Für ihn ist ja Putin das Buch durch der Archetyp des neuen Autokraten, der vor 20 Jahren anfing, deswegen so ganz zaghaft, und vielleicht ist das wirklich so eine mediale Eigenschaft von Putin, als gefährlich zu wirken, gerade weil er so ruhig ist, dieses leichte Lächeln auf der Bühne oder so. Und jetzt ist Putin der Pionier der Autokratie der Neuen, medialen Autokratie, aber gleichzeitig auch der Pionier der Autokraten, die dann wirklich in den Krieg zogen. Und dann schreibt Rachmann, Erfolg der Russen könnte andere Strongmen dazu verleiten, ebenfalls auf Krieg zu setzen. Wir müssten also das heißt, dass den Ukraine-Krieg noch mal unter diesen Pionier-Gesichtspunkten sehen. Und diese Taiwan-Fragen und so weiter, dann doch noch mal daran so ein bisschen anhängen. Das finde ich keinen schlechten Gedanken. Und verleiht dem Buch auch so ein bisschen Gewicht, dadurch, dass das Vorwort und die Realität es jetzt noch mal so eingefangen haben.
Wird hier ein Exempel statuiert, dem man dann folgt? Oder ist das nicht so? Ist das vielleicht das Ende? Ergibt jetzt nicht genau Ratschläge, was zu tun wäre, wie die Unterstützung der Ukraine aussehen könnte. Jedenfalls, wäre damit, meint er, möglicherweise auch so ein Ende dieser autokraten Regierungen eingeleitet. Was ich jedoch nicht glaube. Also eine Niederlage löst noch keinen Domino-Effekt aus. Zumal wir es dadurch, die Bank mit Leuten zu tun haben, mit einem extrem langen Atem, die sich immer wieder aufstellen lassen. Nun, wenn wir uns jetzt ansehen, was ist eigentlich so die These, dann sagt er, es gibt einen neuen Politiker-Typus. Der Archetyp ist dabei Putin. Jemand, der meist aus einfachen Verhältnissen kommt. Dann oft irgendwo eine Karriere gemacht hat, im Sinne von also ein Karrierist sein und hat sich dann irgendwie nach oben gepaart und der das Spiel mit den Medien beherrscht. Also man findet hier keine einzige Figur, die nicht sehr gut mit den Medien umgehen kann, nicht dafür berühmt ist, zu provozieren. Beziehungsweise man könnte es auch gleich, das fehlt ein bisschen in dem Buch, gleich immer auf das Digitale projizieren, der es nicht schafft, viral zu gehen.
Genau, weil dieser Hinweis auf die Mediale, das gilt eben für beides, die alten Medien waren fasziniert. Das haben wir bei Trump gesehen, wie krass das EPS sich auch Werbeeinnahmen versprochen hat durch Abfilmen von Trump-Veranstaltungen. Und dann kennen wir ja aus Italien und so, dieses Ich filme mich in der Küche selber auf dem Sofa oder im Küchenwagen sitzen. In Brasilien genauso. Genau, und dann werden da diese Tiraden losgelassen, die dann viral gehen und so viel Unterstützung generieren. Das kannte man wieder von Putin nicht, da war noch alte Schule und hat sich eben im Stile von dann irgendwie oben ohne fotografieren lassen und so, aber hat das wieder groß gedreht. Bei Modi ist das ja auch ein interessanter Modus. Modi tritt nicht selbst auf mit krassen Reden, aber wenn jemand eine krasse Rede gehalten hat, macht er Selfies mit demjenigen, um dann wieder darzustellen, wo hier die inhaltlichen Nähen sind und so.
Bei Modi heißt es ja, er könne gar nicht ohne Teleprompter irgendetwas sagen.
Genau, also Neo-Autokrat zu sein, bedeutet nicht, dass man selber so krass mit dem Handy umgehen muss, aber die finden immer wieder Wege, es dann doch für sich auszubeuten.
Es geht in dem Buch, um die mal kurz alle zu nennen, um Putin, Erdogan, Xi, Modi, Orban und Kaczynski, Boris Johnson, Trump, Rodrigo Duterte, Mohamed Bin Salman, also wir sind da wieder in Saudi-Arabien, Jared Bolsonaro und Abi Ahmed.
Aber jeweils auch um dann noch Netanyahu. Also er bringt immer noch, so in der Unterzeile des Kapitels, die Konstellation. Netanyahu hat da glaube ich bei MBS mit drin.
Weil die in gewisser Weise sich connecten über Jared Kushner, der Trump-Schwiegersohn. Und diese Connections sind ganz interessant, die er oft zeigt.
Und er hat ja noch mal so eine Art Kartografie gemacht. China und Indien verkoppelt für die zwei größten. Russland und Türkei am Rande Europas, Orban und Kaczynski innerhalb Europas. Und dann Bolsonaro und AMLO, Andres Manuel López Obrador, also in Mexiko. Er linkslastig, wohler wie auch immer. Ich kannte ihn gar nicht so im Detail. Die dann nochmal diese süd-mittelamerikanische Ebene abdecken. Also sie sind überall und sie sind miteinander gut organisiert, auch wenn sie sich nicht immer miteinander gut verstehen. Gerade Russland-Türkei, das wäre echt nochmal eine Geschichte für sich. Die wird gar nicht so deutlich im Buch, wie die Zusammenhänge da sind. Aber was ich am Anfang noch erstaunlich fand in diesem Vorwort. Das Vorwort wurde ja geschrieben, als der Krieg in der Ukraine nur ein paar Monate alt war. Und er verweist nochmal darauf, dass im kalten Krieg der Afghanistan-Einsatz in zehn Jahren zu 15.000 toten sowjetischen Soldaten führte. Und das hat Russland jetzt in einem Monat ereilt. So viele Tote. Also wir haben es hier wirklich mit einem auch historisch wirklich bedeutsamen Krieg zu tun. Was die Investitionen der Strongmen da angeht. Zehn Millionen Ukrainer in die Flucht geschlagen und 15.000 eigene Soldaten allein im ersten Monat da geopfert. Das zeigt schon, hier ist Grupellosigkeit das Programm der Strongmen.
Und er nimmt die Medien und auch sich selbst gleich in die Verantwortung. Er schreibt in der Einleitung dann, die Tendenz westlicher Beobachter, viele Strongmen anfänglich für Liberale zu halten, fügt sich zu einem gewissen Muster. Als Erdogan in der Türkei an die Macht kam, beschrieb ihn die New York Times als einen islamischen Politiker, der auf demokratischen Pluralismus setzt. In ähnlicher Weise sagte der New York Times-Kolumnist Nicolas Christophe 2013 voraus, dass Xi, Zitat, sich an die Spitze neuer Wirtschaftsreformen und wahrscheinlich auch weiterer politischer Öffnung setzen werde. Er gab seiner Hoffnung Ausdruck, dass Mao Zedong könnte vom Platz des himmlischen Friedens entfernt werden. Zwei Jahre später beschrieb Christophs einflussreicher Kollege Thomas Friedman Kronprinz Mohammed bin Salman als reformerischen Wirbelwind von der Mission beseelt, die Regierungsführung in Saudi-Arabien zu transformieren. Als 2017 die Klagen über MBS-Menschenrechtsverletzung lauter wurden, schien Friedman, diese Einwände vom Tisch zu wischen. Als er schrieb, perfekt ist nicht im Angebot. Irgendjemand muss die Aufgabe erledigen, Saudi-Arabien ins 21. Jahrhundert zu schleifen. Und dann gab es da noch diesen britischen Journalisten, der den Aufstieg nach Rendra Modi's 2014 mit folgenden Worten willkommen hieß, Indien braucht einen Stromschlag und Modi ist ein Risiko, das es wert ist, einzugehen. Wer war das? Ich.
Es ist diese Ambivalenz komplett abgebildet, auch auf der rein sachlichen Ebene. Im Vorwort stehen sowohl der Satz, in den 1930er Jahren stürzten Strongmen wie Benito Mussolini, Francisco, Franco, Stalin und Hitler, ihre Nation und die Welt in den Krieg. Putins Überfall auf die Ukraine wiederholt dieses tödliche Muster, zum anderen aber. Aber wenn Putin in der Ukraine besiegt wird, könnte sein Scheitern den Anfang vom Ende des Zeitalters der Autokraten einläuten. Also entweder haben wir es mit einem Vorboten eines dritten Weltkriegs zu tun, allein weil die Egos und ihre katastrophalen Fehler, wenn alles von einzelnen Personen und ihrer Klugheit abhängt oder von einzelnen Männern, wie er sagt. Man kann es ja auf die Männer begrenzen. Dann kann da ganz schön viel abhängen, wie zum Beispiel auch solche Kriegsbeginne. Oder aber alle schauen sich den Weltlauf der Dinge an und stellen fest, diese Sanktionen gegen Russland waren ganz schön hart und gewonnen haben sie den Krieg auch nicht. Also versuchen wir es mal auch auf friedlichem Wege und kaufen Taiwan lieber als das, was sie überfallen. Mal sehen, also das ist hier so ein bisschen, wie gesagt, ambivalent.
Was man deutlich machen muss, ist, dass es nicht darum geht, zu sagen, die sind jetzt alle gleich. In dem Sinne, das sind alles Diktatoren, sondern es geht hier um Autokraten. Was aber sehr viele Autokraten verbindet oder fast alle, über die wir hier sprechen, bis auf Xi und MBS, wenn man es glaube ich genau nimmt, ist, dass sie demokratisch an die Macht gekommen sind, dass sie gewählt wurden. Und da finden wir auch ein Erdogan-Zitat, das sogar zweimal zitiert wird. Da sagt der Erdogan einmal, Demokratie ist wie eine Straßenbahn, die man nimmt, bis man am Ziel angekommen ist. Genau. Und das ist auch eine Beobachtung, die Rachmann macht. Bei allen, die die zweite Amtszeit haben, radikalisiert sich das auf ganz enorme Weise. Also es ist oft noch so, dass die erste Amtszeit, das kann man ja auch für Erdogan im Übrigen sagen, dass die erste Amtszeit tatsächlich liberale Versprechungen hat. Es wird schon mal ein bisschen nach rechts geblinkt, aber es ist noch nicht so deutlich. Und wenn dann die Möglichkeit der zweiten Amtszeit gewehrt wurde, dann setzen sie sich richtig durch. Und das war ja auch diese große Angst, die in den USA war. Wenn Trump noch mal gewählt würde, wäre man sicher, dass sich das in einer Weise radikalisiert, wenn man sich das noch gar nicht vorgestellt hat. Und das ist auch ein Muster, das für alle demokratisch gewählten Autokraten gilt. Für Putin natürlich auch.
Genau. Und er sagt ja noch mal ganz klar, wenn ein Land die Welt so ein bisschen frei halten kann von Autokratien, ist das Amerika, sofern Amerika sich selbst dafür entscheidet, nicht zur Autokratie zu werden. Und Trump, haben wir auch eben gehört, ist fasziniert von Autokraten. Das ist sozusagen Common Sense. Darüber kann man sprechen. Und dann schreibt er, was im Weißen Haus unausgesprochen blieb, war die Tatsache, dass Trump selbst einige autokratische Allüren in das Herz der größten Demokratie der Welt verpflanzt hatte. Ich würde sagen, größte Demokratie, müssen wir mal auf Bevölkerungsgröße. Und der David Axelrod hat ja auch in seinem Podcast jetzt bei der 6. Januar-Kongressaufarbeitung immer wieder darauf hingewiesen, das ist auch Lehrmaterial. Für den Fall, dass wieder Trump oder jemand anders aus dieser Ecke gewinnt, kann man sich da anschauen, was man verhindern muss. Also, das ist medial eben nicht im Nachhinein zu so einer, klar habt ihr das getan, ihr habt nämlich alles dokumentiert sozusagen, sondern dann muss man ein bisschen heimlicher vorgehen. Also, man hat über die Anhörungen zum 6. Januar, zum Sturm aufs Kapitol noch mal die Blaupause gegeben, wie man es nicht organisiert, um nicht aufzufliegen, aber eben alle Macht, die einem demokratisch verliehen wird, zu nutzen, um dann später mit der Straßenbahn in die Enthaltestelle einzufahren und die Demokratie darüber dann zu verlassen. Also, schade eigentlich, dass uns das Buch am Ende dann doch so wenig gibt und wir aber so viele Fragen eigentlich an diese so haben.
Ja, es sind eher so einzelne Anekdoten, die man bekommt, die man vielleicht schon wusste oder die einem jetzt zum ersten Mal aufscheinen. Also zum Beispiel beschreibt der Putin in den Nullerjahren, wie da eine Journalistin ist, die ihm eine Frage stellt. Und er aber nicht auf die Frage antwortet, sondern erst mal erwähnt, dass sie einen unglaublich großen Ring hat mit einem großen Diamanten drauf und das würde ihn jetzt wirklich mal interessieren. Und diese Art der Kommunikation, die finden wir immer mehr. Also dass nicht mehr das formale Antworten gefragt wird, sondern das informelle dann hineinkommt. Und dass damit aber auch so eine Macht ausgedrückt wird, dadurch dass ich sagen kann, ich als Präsident kann einfach mal eine Rückfrage stellen, wie ich es möchte. Und kann auch vom Thema vollkommen weggehen. Also solche kleinen Details sind es, die sinnvoll sind, die er anstellt. Und auch diese Verknüpfung des Autokraten mit dem Land. Also das müssen wir auch noch mal unterscheiden. Also wir haben bei Olaf Scholz einen Bundeskanzler. Der ist aber gewählt. Der ist im Prinzip ein Funktionsträger. Der kann dann mehr oder weniger Charisma haben. Aber Olaf Scholz ist nicht Deutschland. Und wenn Olaf Scholz nicht mehr ist, dann haben wir nicht Sorge um Deutschland. Aber bei den Autokraten ist zum einen natürlich der Autokrat der Staatsmann, aber er ist zugleich auch der Repräsentant der jeweiligen Kultur. Also Erdogan ist die Türkei, ist die türkische Kultur. Das heißt, wer Erdogan kritisiert, kritisiert zugleich die Türken und die türkische Kultur. Und damit hat man eine Verbindung hergestellt, die ein so langes Regieren ermöglicht. Und es auch ganz schwierig macht für Regierungskritiker, beim Volk beliebt zu sein, weil das Volk natürlich jederzeit denkt, ja Moment, aber das ist ja meine Identität. Erdogan ist meine Identität. Wer ihn kritisiert, kritisiert also mich.
Genau, das haben wir. Und da ist er sehr mutig in Israel, wo er Netanyahu begann, das als jüdische Nation zu markieren, wo ja nicht alle Einwohner jüdisch sind in Amerika. Sonderfall, Trump schlägt sich auf die ethnischen weiße Arbeiterschicht, die von sich weiß, sie schrammt gerade knapp noch über die 50%-Linie. In China ist allerdings ganz anders. Die Uguren sind dort eine krasse Minderheit und bedrohen niemanden, was so Umfolgungsgedanken oder so was angeht, dass es da muslimische Evolutionen in der Bevölkerung gibt. Und trotzdem ist man da so hart. Und in Indien, es sind 80% Hindus. Trotzdem tun die so, als würden sie von 80% anderen da irgendwie übernommen. Und da kommt Hindu-Nationalismus da irgendwie rein. Medial, klar lässt sich das dann alles irgendwie abbilden, aber das zeigt schön, egal wie die faktische Grundlage ist, der ethnischen Verteilung, das Argument wird einfach immer gemacht. Und dient damit auch, diese Verwechslung von Staatschef und Staat mitzutragen, wobei hier ganz klar ein Buch drin steht, und das ist auch ein Auftrag an deutsche Medien. Es ist ein Wunsch dieser Autokraten, stellvertretend namentlich für ihr Land zu stehen. Und es ist aber ein Problem in den deutschen Medien, wenn wir immer nur von Putin, Putin, Putin, obwohl man das Wort dann eigentlich mal austauschen müsste mit Russland, Russland, Russland und so weiter. Also wenn man gar nicht mehr wahrnimmt, was da noch stattfindet. Es gab ja immer wieder diese Versuche von Angela Merkel, wenn man schon in China ist, trifft man sich auch noch mit der Zivilgesellschaft. Und das hat ja kein deutscher Journalist jemals in der Härte, in der man das betrachten muss, ernst genommen. Sondern man war immer bei Qi und hat dann auch noch die Opposition besucht. Aber dass es da einfach einen Staat gibt, der von dem Qi nochmal zu unterscheiden ist, der aus mehr besteht als nur Widersacher gegen Qi usw. Sondern dass es da eben noch auch unpolitische Zivilgesellschaft gibt, das findet einfach immer gar nicht mehr statt.
Und wir haben diese Denkweise ja jetzt auch bei der Diskussion um die Visa für Russen, dass man sagt, die sollen erst mal am besten ein Bekenntnis ablegen, dass sie gegen den Krieg sind, also sollen Gesinnungstests machen. Wenn wir das jetzt anfangen einzuführen, dann müssen wir Identitätspolitik an jedem Flughafen betreiben. Also dann kann man aus ganz vielen Ländern Leute befragen, wie stehen sie eigentlich zur Ehe für alle?
Oder eben noch härter, wir stellen fest, sie sind Russen und wir lassen sie da nicht rein. Das ist ja das Ansinnen der osteuropäischen Länder gerade, dass man da einfach wirklich alle in die nationale Sippenhaft nimmt. Es gibt hier am Anfang noch in der Einleitung so einen interessanten historischen Hinweis. Aus den Ruinen des Zweiten Weltkriegs stieg die Freiheit empor, breitete sich 60 Jahre lang auf der ganzen Welt aus. Stets gab es Rückschritte und die Definition dessen, was Demokratie ausmachte, blieb immer etwas unprozise. Aber alles in allem war klar, wohin die Reise ging. 1945 gab es 12 Demokratien und 2002 sind es 92 gewesen. Also hielt sich irgendwie die Waage. Und seitdem hat die Gruppe der Länder, die formal als Demokratien definiert werden, ihren kleinen Vorsprung gegenüber deren autokratischen Regime verteidigt. Aber der Prozess demokratischer Erosion hat begonnen. Also er macht diesen Punkt wahrscheinlich nicht nur, um sein Buchritz zu rechtfertigen, sondern weil das diese Beobachtung ist. Wir sehen jetzt die Verwerfung durch den Krieg. Wir können ihm sagen, ja, das stimmt. Der Druck ist da und er kommt ja dann, finde ich auch erstaunlich, recht deutlich auf Orban und die PiS-Partei in Polen zu sprechen und so. Also es rückt dann schon ziemlich nah ran. Und Frankreich ist ja auch ein Thema.
Auch da, kurios ist ja wirklich. Also einmal Polen, Kaczynski und seine Katzen. Diese Katzenliebe, ich will das einfach mal wiedergeben, wenn man das sonst nicht so häufig, glaube ich, liest. Und zwar sagt er hier, und das wurde ihm von einem Freund Orbans wiederum erzählt, Kaczynski ist die dominante Figur in der regierenden Partei viel mehr als Präsident Duda. Doch er ist auch ein Einsiedler, der kein Englisch spricht und sich zu Hause bei seinen Katzen und seinen Büchern wohler fühlt als auf der Weltbühne. Als er zwischen Juli 2006 und November 2007 kurzzeitig polnischer Ministerpräsident war, wohnte Kaczynski bei seiner Mutter, nicht in der offiziellen staatlichen Residenz, und spendete 20 Prozent seines Gehalts für ein Katzenhilfswerk. Als er an die Macht zurückkehrte, stellte er sich bereitwillig als Schüler Orbans dar, indem er dem ungarischen Ministerpräsidenten 2016 sagte, Viktor Orbán hat gezeigt, dass in Europa vieles möglich ist. Sie haben ein Beispiel gegeben, und wir lernen davon.
Ja, Kaczynski ist sowieso die verrückte Person, die hier drin steht, weil das so gar nicht passt in dieses autokratische Bild. Ich will auf die Bühne, ich will was darstellen, ich will mich mit meinem Land unverwechselbar machen. Nee, da strebt er nicht mal Regierungsämter an, sondern bleibt halt Parteichef einfach, will kein Englisch sprechen, will nicht ins Ausland reisen, vergräbt sich da und kommt dann aber immer mit dieser Kultur- und Ideologiearbeit um die Ecke und macht jetzt auch schon wieder dieses 1,3 Billionen Entschädigungs-Forderung gegen Deutschland-Fass auf und so. Also das ist ganz verrückt.
Und bei Orban hat mich eine Sache sehr gewundert, auf die auch nur kurz eingegangen wird, da könnte man viel mehr zu schreiben. Allerdings hinderte der den ungarischen Regierungschef umgebende Gestank der Korruption ihn nicht daran, die Rolle eines Philosophenkönigs zu spielen. Als Student hatte Orban eine Abhandlung über den italienischen marxistischen Philosophen Antonio Gramsci geschrieben, demzufolge politische Macht oft der Kontrolle wichtiger kultureller Institutionen entspringt. Als Ministerpräsident versuchte er sich an einer gesellschaftlichen Transformation im Geiste Gramscis. Sein erklärtes Ziel war es, eine neue kulturelle Ära einzuleuten. Sogar das Curriculum ungarischer Kindergärten wurde umgestaltet, um nationale Identität, Werte christlicher Kultur und Patriotismus zu fördern. Die Idee ist ja bei Gramsci, dass man dann eine Hegemonie erreicht, also eine politische Vormacht erreicht, wenn man den kulturellen Weg wählt. Beziehungsweise man kann nicht eine politische Vormacht haben, wenn man nicht die kulturelle Vormacht hat. Also das heißt, wenn man nur Menschen hat, die aufs Auto versessen sind und sagen, Mobilität, Individualverkehr ist das Wichtigste, dann kann es nicht passieren, dass die Grünen 50 Prozent bekommen. Wenn man aber einen kulturellen Wandel herstellt, wo man sagt, eigentlich könnte Mobilität ganz anders aussehen und so weiter, dann schafft man das erst mal über den kulturellen Weg und dann ist die politische Vormachtstellung auch möglich. Und diese Kulturpolitik, was jetzt nicht meine Kulturpolitik im Sinne von so Claudia Roth sagt was, sondern Kulturpolitik wirklich als Ganzes begriffen, das ist etwas, was Gramsci beschäftigt, wie man also auch eine Hegemonie erlangen kann, welche Ansprache man wählen muss. Und das ist aber auch etwas, was seit den 70er Jahren in Frankreich von den Neurechten rezipiert wird. Also von Alain de Benoist, der hat auch schon Bücher geschrieben über die kulturelle Hegemonie, wie die von rechts erlangt werden kann. Und ich glaube, mit Gramsci kann man ganz gut so verstehen die ganzen Debatten von Leila bis Winnetou, dass es vor allem den Parteien, die sich da so stark einmischen, also wie zum Beispiel CDU und FDP, nicht wirklich darum geht, dass man sagt, gut, was hängt an diesem Lied Leila, sondern wenn sie eine kulturelle Hegemonie herstellen über ein solches Lied, ist es auch am Ende leichter, wenn dann Christian Lindner sagen würde, jetzt müssen wir mal die Steuern für die Reichen abschaffen.
Ja, da ist Orban wahrscheinlich den weitesten Weg gegangen und auch den cleversten, denn er wird ja hier noch mal beschrieben als der 26-Jährige, der dann irgendwie gegen die letzten Kommunisten ankämpft und mit so einer Rede auf so einem Marktplatz da einfach wirklich die Leute plötzlich für sich begeistert und auch die Medien auf sich aufmerksam macht, relativ zügig Fidesz Parteichef wird, die damals eben noch eine andere Rolle spielt, recht progressiv und so. Und er selber hat ja auch persönlich sehr viel von George Soros-Stipendien und so weiter profitiert. Aber sobald er die Macht hatte, hat er zuerst die Medien beseitigt und sie einfach allen geschenkt, um da Hoheit über diese medialen Themen. Und erst danach kam der restliche Umbau. In Polen haben sie es ja versucht, gleichzeitig zu machen. Aber das mediale System war noch nicht so weit, um einfach zu akzeptieren, dass das ganze Juristerei-Gramm da umgebaut wird. Und dann wurde auch Europa wieder aufmerksam. Das hat Orban irgendwie mit viel Geduld anders geregelt, zuerst das Mediensystem zertrümmert.
Und so müssen wir auch in diesen ganzen Debatten um den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen immer Augenrahmen. Ich meine, ich äußere mich ja auch laufend kritisch über Funk oder irgendwelche Kultursendungen, die nichts mit Kultur zu tun haben. Aber das ist wirklich, muss ich nochmal betonen, nie in diese Richtung, dass man irgendwann dieses System abschaffen muss. Denn da ist tatsächlich diese Gefahr, die da entsteht. Und man weiß ja genau, man kann sich das ja mal ganz schnell ausmalen. Es gibt einen Film, der heißt Free Rainer. Ich weiß nicht, ob du den mal gesehen hast. Der ist ganz interessant.
Rainer?
Ja, da werden die ganzen Quoten, Messgeräte manipuliert. Und da kommt dann heraus, dass die Leute nur noch Arte und Reisert sich ansehen. Und dann gibt es so einen Kulturwandel. Und jetzt kann man sich das aber auch mal als Dystopie vorstellen. Nehmen wir mal an, wir hätten mal den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen abgeschafft. Und jetzt können wir ja mal so im Kopf durchgehen, wer dann wo noch mehr platziert ist. Ich vermute, es sind dann nicht die Neuen Zwanziger. Und auch nicht Le Monde Diplomatiek.
Ich fand es ein bisschen überraschend, dieses 2015er Jahr hier nochmal zu hören. Denn es war nicht nur die Flüchtlingskrise, sondern auch Charlie Hebdo im Frühjahr. Also wir hatten nur wenige Monate zwischen Charlie Hebdo, dieser Angriff muslimischer Seite sozusagen. Januar, genau. Und dann die Flüchtlinge, das war dann irgendwann September oder so. Und Orban hat beides ganz konstruktiv als Brandbeschleuniger benutzt, um diese Nationalkultur-Ideologie-Arbeit aufzuziehen. Damals konnte George Soros noch einen Gastartikel in der Zeitung schreiben und dafür plädieren, dass die EU sich für eine Million Flüchtlinge als Immigranten bereit macht. Und das geht heute nicht mehr. Und die Welt von außen bricht über uns herein. Und wir wissen ja, wie alle in Europa gelitten haben und die gar nicht mehr konstruktiv bei den ganzen EU-Räten zusammensitzen konnten und überhaupt nicht mehr entscheidungsfähig waren. Orban ganz anders. Der hat das einfach ganz konstruktiv genutzt für sich. Der hat diese Medien umgebaut, hat diese Stimmung gemacht, hat gegen George Soros gewettert, hat die EU als irgendwie plakatiert und so weiter. Und hat darüber aber immer darauf geachtet, dass er Unterstützung mobilisiert für sich, die ihm dann bis zu dieser 70 Prozent Parlamentsmehrheit brachte, die er dann auch wieder hingebogen hatte durch die Änderungen der Regeln und so weiter. Also Orban als EU-Mitgliedsstaat so, man kann ihm fast gratulieren eigentlich, das geschafft zu haben. Jetzt so langsam schlägt die...
In dem Land, in dem sie nicht wirtschaftlich bedeutend für die...
In der Unaufmerksamkeit der europäischen Debatten untergegangen. Jetzt so langsam kommt die EU-Kommission und sagt, wir knüpfen dann doch mal auch echte Sanktionen an die Rechtsstaatlichkeit und Budgets fließen dann nicht mehr und so. Und das macht ihm ja auch echt Sorgen. Aber das war interessant in dieser Deutlichkeit, das hier nochmal zu lesen bei ihm.
Was mich auch überrascht hat, war bei all den Gemeinsamkeiten, die die Autokraten hatten, welche Feindeslinien da zum Teil vermessen werden. Also zum Beispiel Kaczynski und Putin. Nun ist es ja so, dass der Bruder von Kaczynski ja umgekommen ist bei diesem Flugunglück. Und dass der überlebende Zwillingsbruder dann immer wieder sagt, hier heißt es dann stattdessen verbreitet er und so. Also man weiß, es handelte sich bloß um einen Unfall. Das ist eigentlich geklärt. Aber stattdessen verbreitete Kaczynski und seine Gefolgsleute die Theorie, Russland stecke hinter der Ermordung eines großen Teils der polnischen Elite und die polnische Regierung habe die Belege verheimlicht. Manchmal legt Kaczynski sogar nahe seine polnischen politischen Gegner sein direkt für den Tod seines Brudes verantwortlich. Im Parlament rief er den Oppositionsbänken zu, ihr habt ihn zerstört, ihr habt ihn getötet. Also, dass auch so eine ganz private Fede gegen Russland und die Opposition dann noch mal gefahren wird.
Ja, dieses Unglück von Smolensk ist, das haben wir hier überhaupt nicht auf dem Schirm, welche Bedeutung das in Polen hat. Das sind immer wieder ganz erstaunliche Sachen. Über diese Bücher erfährt man es dann immer noch mal. Leider ist es trotzdem so, obwohl es so interessant wäre, die polnische und die ungarische Geschichte genauer anzuschauen, weil es da eben wirklich um das Umdrehen, nicht nur von Demokratien, sondern auch von Demokratien, die eigentlich eingebettet sind. In dem Falle dann die europäische Struktur. So richtig deutlich, oder sagen wir mal so, die Fragestellungen, die man hat, werden eigentlich, finde ich, nur so in diesem Vladimir-Putin-Kapitel am Anfang. So ein bisschen erklärt, wie kommt man wirklich zu dieser Macht. Wir hatten jetzt im Fernsehpodcast diese Aufarbeitungen des heutigen Journals zum Thema Gorbatschow gestorben. Da haben die original einfach gesagt, ja, er kam aus einem kleinen Dorf, fuhr dann nach Moskau und irgendwann war er es, der die Paraden abnahm. Das ist halt einfach passiert irgendwie. Man wird so ganz automatisch in so einem Land dann irgendwie der Chef dieser Staatsapparate. Das ist ja hier bei Putin ganz anders, denn bei Putin gibt es viel zu sagen, weil das in diese allgemeine Umbruchszeit viel, als Putin als Agent in Dresden sitzt, auf Befehle aus Moskau wartet und es gibt aber keine. Dann fragt er sich selber, was mache ich jetzt aus der Situation? Wie viel Glück ist dabei und wie viel Gelegenheit nutzen? Was ich vorher nicht wusste, was hier gut dargestellt wird, Putin kam irgendwann in die Rolle, die präsidentiellen Immobilienvermögen zu verwalten, was ja eine sehr krasse informale Macht ist, weil man da über seine Unterschrift sehr viel hin- und herschieben kann. Also sehr vielen, was zugutekommen lassen kann irgendwie. Und er kümmerte sich immer ganz rührend um die Vermögen der Mächtigen, bis er dann selber so ein Mächtiger wurde. Und dann aber diesen Apparat auch kannte, so wie ich es auch gut finde, dass Olaf Scholz eben vorher Finanzminister war, der mit dem Linden dann nicht allzu sehr auf der Nase tanzte, und er auch noch mal weiß, wo man da anrufen kann. Und Putin hat diesen Apparat von Ihnen kennengelernt als Agent und dann als dieser, ich verwalte hier das Vermögen und so. Und dann konnte ich mir ein bisschen besser vorstellen, wie das dann funktioniert. Dieses Weiterverteilen von, was ja auch Orban so ins Nest gesetzt hat.
40% aller Staatsaufträge gehen an Freunde.
Man hat so seinen Lieblingskoch und gibt ihm erst mal den Auftrag, das ganze Land mit Schulessen. Und dann ist ja natürlich der, weil einfach Hunderte, zig Millionen Kinder dann plötzlich von ihm versorgt werden. Und dann summiert sich eben die Beträge irgendwie hoch. Und dann hat man so ein Netz sich gebaut, wo jemand mal so richtig profitiert. Also Putin, auch diese Geschichte 2007 Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz, das ist dann sechs, sieben Jahre nach seiner Rede im Bundestag gewesen, wo er noch diese eurasische Sicherheitsarchitektur auch als Reaktion auf den 11. September vorstellt. 2007 aber dann der große Angriff Putin gegen die westliche Welt. Und eigentlich kann man das Jahr 2022 dann komplett zurückziehen, diesen roten Faden bis auf 2007, so wird es hier jedenfalls dargestellt. Wir haben ja die parallelen Geschichtsschreibungen von Christoph Heusgen und so, der noch drei Tage vorher sich nicht vorstellen konnte, dass Putin wirklich angreift, aber hier liest man wieder, nee eigentlich steckt das 2007 schon drin. 2014 insbesondere, was ich auch wieder nicht wusste, also ich wusste beides aber nicht, wie es zusammenhängt. 2014 die Grim-Annektion ist gleichzeitig mit diesem EU-Assoziierungsversuch, der dann nur durch die nicht-gegebene Mehrheit in den Niederlanden und so nicht zustande kam und sowas. Also das ist auch wieder in 2014, dass natürlich die Grim-Annektion auch eine Reaktion auf, ihr wolltet mir die ganze Ukraine nehmen, ich schneide mir jetzt mal einen Teil daraus. Also dass das so ein 1 zu 1 ist, 2 Moment eigentlich war, wusste ich gar nicht mehr, aber hier steht es nochmal gut drin.
Nun, sprechen wir mal ein bisschen auf so einer generellen Ebene. Jetzt haben wir es mit Xi mit einem Spezialfall zu tun, weil er Leiter dieser Partei ist, Chef der Partei ist und Chef des Landes ist und sich mit China identifiziert. Und da haben wir vielleicht noch stärker einen Träger von Ideologie, wenngleich man auch fragen muss, welche ist denn das denn da genau. Denn wir werden im Buch erfahren, was vor allem in China rezipiert wird, ist Carl Schmitt. Aber wir haben ja auch schon festgestellt, wann immer wir uns mit Xi reden, beschäftigt haben, der Marxismus-Leninismus wird mal aufgerufen. Aber nie ist auch nur ein einziger Gedanke, das Marxismus oder das Leninismus da zu finden. Aber sagen wir mal, da gibt es noch irgendeine ideologische Grundlage, die sich offenbar laufend wandelt. Bei MBS können wir es gar nicht sagen, was ist da Ideologie, ist er ein konservativer Irgendwo dann doch und ist nur ein bisschen liberaler als seine Vorgänger. Aber bei all den anderen ist ja doch erstaunlich, wie wenig sie im Sinne eines Fanatismus ideologisch sind. Also wenn wir jetzt mal an jemanden wie Hitler zum Beispiel denken, dann haben wir ja jemanden, der zutiefst, und das dann auch auf hunderten Seiten ausgeführt hat, zutiefst Antisemit ist, zutiefst dem völkischen Glauben anhängt. Wir haben aber hier Figuren, die wissen, es gibt irgendetwas in der Bevölkerung eines jeden Landes, das man affiziert, wenn man sagt, ja und die LGBT-Rechte, die machen unsere Familien kaputt und und und. Also diese ganzen Dinge, ich muss sie nicht wiederholen. Dass das irgendwas ist, was aber dann funktioniert als Ideologie, obwohl wir nicht Ideologen in dem Sinne haben. Also da würde ich ja mal bei fast allen, von denen wir hier lesen, im Buch behaupten, die würden auch genau das Gegenteil machen, wenn das für sie sinnvoller wäre. Nur es wird immer was Repressives sein in irgendeiner Weise, aber es ist nicht festgelegt auf irgendwas. Also es ist ja auch in dem Kapitel, wo es um Saudi-Arabien geht und auch die ganzen Autokraten, die sich mit Nitanyau gut verstanden haben. Also dass man plötzlich sagt, ach ja, jetzt ist Israel uns mal gerade wichtig, aber nicht aus irgendeinem Kampf gegen den Antisemitismus verstanden. Nee, man kann sogar beides. Also man kann sogar sagen, ich versuche, Kontakt zu pflegen mit Nitanyau und mach noch zugleich. Und da spricht er dann auf Orban an, mach zugleich noch antisemitischen Wahlkampf, indem ich Soros als den großen, bösen Juden darstelle.
Ja, es geht drunter und drüber. Und im Epilog schreibt er auch, Strongmen sind Fuscher, die sich eben da einfach wild bedienen. Am Ende geht es darum, diese Straßenbahn zu fahren, also die Gesetze, die man vorfindet, nur noch als Waffe gegen die Gegner zu verwenden und gar nicht mehr als das Institutionengefüge, das den Staat eigentlich darstellt, dem ich mal kurz diene.
Aber dann ist es ja was ganz Individualistisches, also es ist ja oder sagen wir idiosynkratisches, dass man sagt, ich will Präsident sein, ich will hart regieren, ich will, dass Menschen vor mir Angst haben, mich andere aber auch bewundern. Und dazu wende ich die jeweils notwendigen Mittel an und bediene entsprechende performative Elemente, wie sie vonnöten sind und wie ich sie ausrichten kann. Aber es geht nicht mehr darum, dass jemand eine Mission in dem Sinne hat. Also das ist ja vollkommen missionslos. Also es geht ja auch in keiner einzigen Vorstellung darum, dass man sagt, und so stelle ich mir jetzt ein schönes Europa vor. Ja, also das war ja das Versprechen der Diktatoren der Vergangenheit, war ja schon auch in die Zukunft gerichtet. Also das ist ja was interessantes, wenn man sich zum Beispiel mit den Faschisten, Mussodini, Franco oder Hitler beschäftigt, dann ist ja da eine Utopie, die selbstverständlich eine Dystopie ist, aber eine Utopie von deren Seite aus betrachtet, ausgemalt, die sagt, und so sieht dann unser Land bald aus, wenn die und die alle nicht mehr da sind oder so. Und dieses Moment gibt es ja hier überhaupt nicht mehr, sondern es gibt ja eigentlich nur ein Chaos-Stiften, wie dann dann mit Law and Order regieren. Man verspricht natürlich schon mal so was wie, es werden keine Drogen bald mehr genommen oder so was. Das Problem lösen wir. Aber es ist eigentlich nur noch der Bezug auf irgendwas Vergangenes.
Genau, der zieht sich ja durch.
Aber nicht mehr auf was zukünftiges.
Genau. Putin hat das ja mitgebracht, diese Idee von mit meiner Hilfe schließen wir an, an die Zeit, als es den Menschen gut ging und das Land groß war. Und Rachmann stellt ihn uns als den Prototypen des neuen Autokraten vor. Und Trump hat das ja genau kopiert. Mit mir schließen wir wieder an, als America mal great war. Und jetzt machen wir es again. Also dieser totale Rückbezug.
Eigentlich sind es ja dann Endzeitgestalten. Ich meine, du sprichst heute noch über Bunker. Aber eigentlich ist das schon so eine Bunkerpolitik.
Es ist auf jeden Fall interessant, dass man hiermit ja eigentlich Debatten aus dem Weg geht, weil man sich einfach drauf verlässt, wenn ich nur die Signalworte in den Raum stelle, früher, Vergangenheit, die gute alte Heimat und so, dann muss man das nicht weiter verargumentieren, sondern die Leute fühlen das einfach. Weil man jetzt, so wie du, eine neue Ideologie, ich meine, wenn die da in China Schmitts Großraumtheorie lesen und das auf die Meere dann irgendwie, das verfängt ja nicht. Nee, das ist für deren Stinktanks interessant. Genau, das müsste sie dann auch erklären und so. Deswegen verpflichtet sie ja auch alle, die müssen dann Selfies machen, wie sie seine Reden schauen, damit sie auch wirklich alle dreieinhalb Stunden dabei sind. Das ist ja kein Modell, das jetzt irgendwie flächendeckend funktioniert. Ja, sobald man heute eine neue Idee vorstellt, macht man sich angreifbar, weil irgendwer eine andere neue Idee hat. Und dann hat man dieses Spiel der Ideen, wenn man einfach nur an die Vergangenheit erinnert und sie noch mal zurückholen möchte, dann ist das das Programm. So, und wenn dann jemand anders kommt und sagt, ich will das aber auch, dann konkurriert man um die gleiche Idee, aber nicht zwei Ideen. Und dann setzt sich derjenige da durch, der die bessere Show abzieht.
Ich finde es wahnsinnig banal, weißt du? Ich liebe ja die Theorie sehr und ich muss mich hier mit Menschen beschäftigen, die nicht mehr einen Theoriebezug haben. Dann bin ich im letzten Kapitel schon froh oder im vorletzten, wenn es dann heißt, ja, Karl Schmitt spielt für Steve Bannon eine Rolle, Orban kennt Karl Schmitt, da und dort wird Karl Schmitt gelesen in den chinesischen Universitäten gibt es ein Karl Schmitt Revival bzw. viele entdecken ihn jetzt zum ersten Mal. Das finde ich noch interessant, da kann ich noch was geopolitisches ableiten, weil die Großraumtheorie sagt, man darf sich nicht in andere Großräume einmischen, jeder Großraum macht, was er will für sich. Und das war natürlich von Karl Schmitt auch im Zuge des zweiten Weltkriegs geschrieben, wo er sich einfach eine Intervention verbeten hat natürlich. Und es ist also eine interessante Theorie, jedenfalls, weil sie anti-universalistisch ist. Und das ist ja was, wir hatten auch mal so einen Shizhek-Text hier im Salon, dass dieser Anti-Universalismus von den einzelnen Autokraten ja vertreten wird, klar, weil jeder möchte ja machen, was er will, der Duterte möchte einfach Leute erschießen und auch noch damit prahlen. Putin will in Länder einmarschieren und Xi will die Leute dazu zwingen, dass sie vier Stunden lang seine Videos gucken und die Uiguren werden auch weggepackt. Und jeder soll jetzt da machen, wie er will und nicht gestört werden. In meiner Badewanne bin ich der Kapitän und ich lese das alles und finde diese verrückten Details bis hin zur Katzenliebe von Kaszinski und muss aber sagen, aber gibt es nicht noch irgendwas Höheres? Also diese Sehnsucht von mir nach Theorie, verstehst du die? Und dann habe ich hier, es sind einfach ganz banale Menschen.
Ja, diese Liebe der Theorie, manchmal ist es ja auch, aus Verlegenheit weiß man nicht, wie es geht. Ich kann dir aus privater, anekdotischer Erfahrung von gestern kurz berichten. Es ist also hier Schuleinführung und es geht darum, auch die in der Schule tätigen, aber nicht so richtig präsenten Organisationen vorzustellen, wie zum Beispiel ein Förderverein. Elternbeirat und sowas, das kennt man ja aus dem Kindergarten, Förderverein ist in der Grundschule neu. Und für Eltern, die ihre Kinder zum ersten Mal einschulen, das erste Kind mitbringen, ist das neu. Was ist ein Förderverein? Und dann wurde ich gebeten, kurz den Förderverein vorzustellen. Und ich habe mir dann auch überlegt, was sage ich jetzt? Stehe ich vorne und mache das wie alle Fördervereinsvorstände, die dann so, ja, also der Förderverein macht so diese und diese und diese Aufgabe. Sie können sich ja überlegen, ob sie da irgendwie unterstützen wollen, wie auch immer. Nein, ich gehe natürlich nach vorne und sage, liebe Eltern, ich bin hier, um den Förderverein vorzustellen. Ich bin aber auch hier als Vater, der heute zum dritten Mal ein Kind einstellt, die Schule bringt, einschult. Ich weiß also, wie sie sich gerade fühlen. Sie wollen einfach nur, dass vormittags der Unterricht läuft und nachmittags die Betreuung. Wozu brauche ich noch ein Förderverein? So, also erst mal Hook nehmen. Wie fühle ich mich eigentlich gerade? Und dann sage ich, ja, aber wissen sie, wenn Stadt und Land sagen, wir machen nur ein halbes Jahr Schwimmunterricht, dann kommt der Förderverein und finanziert die zweite Hälfte. Er sichert also den Unterricht, der ihnen gerade so wichtig ist. Und für die Nachmittagsbetreuung ist er der Träger. Sie werden ihn also nicht sehen, aber ohne den Förderverein können sie ihr Kind nicht 7.30 Uhr eine Stunde vor Schulbeginn hierherbringen. Sie profitieren also sehr davon, dass es hier einen Förderverein gibt. Und außerdem müssen sie sich überlegen, umso mehr Alltagsaction sie sich in der Schule wünschen, umso häufiger stößt man an die Grenzen der Schulbudgets und der Klassenkasse, und dann kommt wieder der Förderverein und kann unterstützen. Und wenn sie sich das wünschen, dass hier viel los ist in der Schule, dann müssen sie den Förderverein unterstützen. Werden sie bitte Mitglied? Bezahlen sie, kaufen sie sich ein T-Shirt und so weiter und so fort. Also, wir müssen es halt, und das verstehe ich dann gut, wie so Autokratien funktionieren, diesen medialen Moment, wenn man weiß, ah, jetzt schauen sie alle zu. Und Gie ist der Einzige, der das einfach missbraucht und die langweiligsten Reden der Welt hält, formal gesehen.
Aber nur, weil er es kann. Weil er nicht wiedergewählt wird. Also er wird zwar gewählt, aber wir wissen, wie das Prozedere läuft.
Er hängt nicht von seinem Wahlpublikum an, dem freien Feld. So, also, sobald man so ein Publikum kurz an die Angel nehmen möchte, versetzt man sich das hinein und fragt sich, wie fühlen die sich und was wünschen die sich. Und dann adressiert man genau das. Ja, und es beginnt bei solchen kleinen Vorstellungsrunden des Fördervereins, statt einfach die Liste abzuhagen, was in der Satzung des Fördervereins steht. Und so funktioniert es dann auch in der großen Politik. Und umso mehr die Medien einem das einfach machen, umso besser kann man diesen Weg auch gehen. Aber, und das ist ja dann so interessant, jeder Autokrat findet eben so seinen ganz eigenen Weg. Putin macht das über diese Bilder und viel Schweigen und sich viel vertrösten lassen und gar nicht da sein, sich rarmachen und so weiter. Aber wenn er dann präsent ist, so richtig präsent zu sein, dann haben wir Bolsonaro, der einfach in jedes Mikrofon schreit, dass ihm da irgendwie hingehalten wurde in diesen Wahlkämpfen. In Italien, wie hieß er noch mal, der Lega-Chef, der Innenminister?
Salvini.
Salvini, genau. Der einfach in der Küche saß, mit seinem Handy und da reingeplärt hat. Und damit die Sehgewohnheit rechter vieler Italiener, die nämlich auch nur das Handy machen können.
Und so bekomme ich ja auch von meinem Onkel ein Video geschickt. Also das ist ja die Assoziation, die direkt da ist.
Genau, und man kann dann so weit gehen, selbst bei Macron und Merkel. Die haben halt diese, die wussten halt, wie ihr Publikum drauf ist. Bei Macron, oh, ein junger Mann, der eine Doktorarbeit zum Thema so und so geschrieben hat. Und bei Merkel halt auch diese Physikerin und so. Der Dunster, die macht das schon, das ist der wissenschaftliche Weg. Ich war ja schlecht in Mathe, aber zum Glück war die Kanzlerin gut in Mathe und so. Ja, dass man so diese deutsche Geruhseiligkeit dann da reinholt. Und ja, aber da ist das Buch leider, obwohl es sich die Person so einzeln vornimmt, werden diese Mechanismen in der biografischen Gestaltung, welche Gelegenheiten werden genutzt, welche werden ihnen auch geboten durch die demokratischen Institutionen, die dann so langsam abgeholt werden. Da ist so ein bisschen schwach, obwohl der Autor so viel immer erklärt, wen er getroffen hat und so.
Er hat alle getroffen und gesehen, er war in allen Ländern. Jedemal irgendwie am Tisch gesessen. Und ich glaube, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen das Problem, dass er mit jedem Mal geredet hat und all das. Und ich hatte beim Lesen mitunter den Gedanken, und jetzt müsste jemand kommen, der das Buch nimmt und so ein Buch drüber schreibt. Nämlich eines, das das ein bisschen sortiert und ordnet. Und diese Frage, die ich jetzt eben gestellt habe, inwieweit sind die Ideologischen im Sinne? Du hast sie jetzt sehr gut mit dieser Anekdote von gestern beantwortet. Man kann sie auch anders beantworten mit Boris Johnson. Da habe ich noch mal ein Detail erfahren. Davon wusste ich überhaupt nicht. Und zwar heißt es da, in Wirklichkeit stand ein viel größeres Kalkül hinter seiner Entscheidung. Also Boris Johnson, wie das nun ist, dass er pro Brexit, gegen Brexit und so weiter. Hinweise, wozu sich Johnson durchringen würde, finden sich in der Biografie, die er über seinen politischen Helden schrieb. Wusste man, dass er eine Churchill-Biografie geschrieben hat. Darin heißt es, zu einem gewissen Grad sind alle Politiker Spieler, was die Geschehnisse angeht. Sie versuchen vorauszusehen, was passieren wird, damit sie auf der richtigen Seite stehen. Johnson bewertete selbst Churchills Kampf gegen den Nationalsozialismus. Wo man ja noch sagen würde, das ist ja ganz klar, dass man da auf der Seite des Guten steht oder so was. Gegen den Nationalsozialismus in diesem doch sehr zynischen Licht, als er schrieb, dass in den 1930er Jahren als Churchills Karriere auf dem Tiefpunkt stand, er sein letztes Hemd auf ein Pferd namens Anti-Nationalsozialismus setzte. Seine Wette ging dann auf spektakuläre Weise auf. Ich musste an diese Textstelle denken, als Boris im Februar 2016 verkündete, er würde für den Brexit kämpfen. Damals schrieb ich in einem Artikel, Herr Johnson hat auf ein Pferd gesetzt, das sich Europaskepsis nennt. Offensichtlich hofft er, dass auch diese Wette auf spektakuläre Weise aufgehen wird und ihm, wie Winston Churchill, direkt einen Platz in Nummer 10 Downing Street sichert. Und diese Art der Sichtweise, also Politik als Spiel, als Kalkül und ohne etwas, also nur als Signifikanth, ohne Signifikat, also nur als Zeichen, ohne den Inhalt beziehungsweise den Gehalt, den kann man jeweils wieder neu füllen, wo man es gerade braucht. Dann mal Anti-Nationalsozialismus und sonst was. Also das würde ich jetzt nicht Churchill unterstellen, aber dass er, dass Johnson so weit geht, dass Churchill zu unterstellen, das lässt tief blicken. Und es hat mir jetzt auch wieder gezeigt, man muss jetzt schon mal gucken, hat Liz Truss auch ein Buch über irgendjemand geschrieben oder so? Da stehen, glaube ich, dann immer die interessantesten Antworten drin.
Ja, das ist ein sehr guter, finaler Gedanke, weil er nochmal anschließt an, was ich vorhin schon versuchte. Und ich weiß, das ist immer ein ganz schwieriges Argument, so einen linken Populismus zu fordern. Und diese Einsicht, am Ende ist es nur ein Spiel. Es gibt, und ich sage es explizit in der Systemtheorie, dieses Bild der Abroximationshoffnung, dieser völligen Abkehr von irgendwelchen ontologischen, also so ist es aber wirklich, das ist die echte Wahrheit und so. Wir sind hier im Sozialen, das ist alles nur so ein Gefüge, das ist extrem perspektivenabhängig. Und man hat immer nur nicht nur eine Perspektive, sondern das macht es ja sozial, dass verschiedene Leute draufschauen und jeder sieht was anderes. Es erfordert viel Kommunikation, man kann nicht in Köpfe reingucken, also muss man sich verständigen, wie macht man es. Gerade in dieser Massenmedialen, man regiert 80 Millionen Menschen. Das kann man nicht im Dialog klären und so weiter, sondern hier kommt es darauf an, wie man vorspielt, was man eigentlich versuchte zu sagen, ohne selber zu wissen, ob man mit seinem eigenen Weg, dem man gerade als Politiker geht, so richtig im Reinen ist oder irgendwelche Chancen verpasst hat oder irgendwas noch besser machen müsste und so. Und Boris Johnson ist so ein Paradebeispiel dafür, und das schreibt ja Rachmann auch ganz deutlich, sich mit seiner eigenen Familie zu überwerfen, um so einen Ego-Trip, es könnte mich der Brexit-Weg in die Regierungsämter führen. Das ist jetzt einfach eine Wette, die gehe ich so ein. Und dann mache ich das einfach. Und das ist in extremer Weise, wie Politik nun mal trotzdem funktioniert. Und jetzt kann man einfach nur hoffen und fordern, dass es weniger extrem gemacht wird. Aber man kommt aus diesem Spiel nicht raus, aus diesem Spielmodus. Es ist ein Spiel. Und jetzt muss man das einfach akzeptieren. Und sollte sich dann wünschen, dass die Politiker, die einem innerlich nahestehen, das Spiel einfach besser mitspielen.
Und das wundert mich auch immer wieder, wie Journalisten sich jeden Tag aufs Neue wundern. Wenn zum Beispiel die SPD dann übers Wochenende sich doch mal überlegt, na, wir müssen mal mit diesen Entlastungspaketen und so, wir gehen jetzt noch mal voraus einen Schritt und sagen, wir wollen das und das haben. Und dann regen sich Grüne und Journalisten, denen ich unterstelle, dass sie die Grünen ganz toll finden. Unglaublich darüber auf, dass die SPD jetzt da den Koalitionspartner fand, da muss ich sagen, nein, das ist jetzt das Spiel. Die haben jetzt irgendwas in den Hinterkammern ausbaldobert. Das hat alles nicht so richtig geklappt. Und dann hat wahrscheinlich Scholz dann gesagt, Feuer frei, jetzt machen wir es mal auf diese Weise. Und so funktioniert die Politik. Und da kann man nicht naiv sein. Alles andere wäre wirklich so ein Denken, treffen sich fünf Vernünftige und resonieren jetzt nur darüber, was ist das Vernünftigste, was wir gemeinsam tun können. Aber das hat dann mit Politik nichts zu tun. Das hat eben diese Sphäre der Interessen. Das kann man tatsächlich auch bei Karl Schmidt lernen. Also ich würde dir auch mal empfehlen, Karl Schmidt von links zu lesen. Vielleicht noch ein kleines Detail, was ich interessant fand, dass Rachmann den deutschen Botschafter Peter Wittig fragte, ob er sich vorstellen könne, dass Benin Schmitt gelesen hat. Hatte er auch Schmitt gelesen? Diese Frage diskutierte ich bei einem Frühstück 2019 mit Peter Wittig, dem ehemaligen deutschen Botschafter in Washington, der zu diesem Zeitpunkt in gleicher Funktion in London tätig war. Er war sich recht sicher, dass Benin sich mit Schmitts Denken auseinandergesetzt hatte. Tatsächlich habe ich ihm einige der Arbeiten Schmitts zur Lektüre mitgegeben. Ich dachte, es würde ihn interessieren. Der Botschafter machte eine Pause und sah etwas leidend aus. Vielleicht war das ein Fehler. So schöne Abschnitte gibt es auch in diesem Buch. Aber sonst ist es eine durchwachsende Materialsammlung. Wer sich noch gar nicht mit diesen Autokraten beschäftigt hat, kann sich da einen Überblick verschaffen. Das ist sicherlich nicht schlecht. Das letzte Buch von Rachmann fand ich wesentlich lesenswerter. Das ist grob drüber. Da muss man selbst viel mit reingeben. Aber vielleicht noch eine Hoffnung, diese enge Bindung der Autokraten zum Volk, zum Nationalen, zum ganzen Land, das ist etwas, was natürlich steht und fällt mit den Autokraten. Da gibt es am Ende noch einen kurzen Abschnitt, wo Rachmann sagt, die müssen gesund bleiben. Da kann sich dann doch noch mal das eine oder andere ändern. Die leben nicht ewig. Da sind auch einige schon sehr alt. Da muss man schauen. Aber auch da gilt es vorsichtig zu sein. Oft sehen wir da, es kommt nichts besseres nach.
Ich will auch noch mal an den letzten Gedanken, weniger den roten Faden aus dem Buch, als unseren roten Faden, den wir am Anfang aufgemacht haben. Außenwelt, Innenwelt, worauf hat man Zugriff und was muss man erleiden, aber kann es eben umprogrammieren in dem Maß, in dem es die Innenwelt erreicht. Und was kann man aus diesem autokratischen Spielen einfach für sich lernen? Ich hatte gestern den kleinen Auftrag noch, den Elternbeirat zu fotografieren. Weil die werden ja dann am Schultor ausgehangen, damit alle Eltern wissen, das sind meine Ansprechpartner. Und in diesem Moment musste ich wieder an Danny denken, der mir mal erzählte, dass er früher so Kurse gegeben hat.
Der Künstler.
Der Künstler Danny aus Köln, genau, Danny Freda. Eine Stunde, wie verhalte ich mich in einem Foto, wenn ich nicht oft fotografiert werde? Also nicht dieses, ja gut, dann machen wir das Fotoschnell, ich werde ja nicht so oft fotografiert, das eine Mal schaffe ich jetzt auch, sondern wenn ich gerade nicht oft fotografiert werde, trotzdem so tun, als ob man es könnte. Denn diese kleinen Fotos, die da entstehen, die sind ja nicht fürs Privatarchiv, sondern die hängen am Schultor und zwar über Jahre. Will man sich jetzt wirklich in einer Situation, in der man so ein bisschen, ah jetzt fotografieren ist ja eh viel Trubel und so, na gut, dann bringen wir es schnell hinter uns. Nein, man muss in diesen Momenten akzeptieren, dass das einfach für die Ewigkeit ist, so halb. So und dann muss man sich diesem Spiel kurz ergeben. Auch wenn man sich, was die Situation selbst betrifft, kurz albern vorkommt. Aber man muss es einfach machen. Denn gerade als Elternbeirat oder so, wo man ja sozusagen Adresse ist, umso mehr Selbstbewusstsein man ausstrahlt auf solchen Fotos, umso kürzer sind die Nachrichten, die einen erreichen von den Eltern, weil die nämlich dann immer schon mitschwingt. Ich weiß, es reicht dir, die Signalworte hinzulegen. Ich vertraue dir, dass du das dann ordentlich an die Schule weiterleitest, umso mehr Unsicherheit in solchen Fotos drin steckt. Umso länger sind diese Nachrichten, weil die Leute dann glauben, jetzt haben wir auch noch so einen Elternbeirat, der so ein bisschen verdammt aussieht. Jetzt muss ich dem auch noch die ganze Zeit erklären, was ich eigentlich will und so. Und da gibt es sehr viele Gewinne über das Spiel einfach richtig mitspielen. Und das ist begegnet einer auf allen Ebenen und in deren Sicht sollten wir ganz großes Interesse für diese Autokraten haben und einfach auf nächste Bücher hoffen, in denen uns das mal wieder so ein bisschen in Prinzipien erklärt wird, damit wir auch frei von der Leber weg dann sagen können, liebe unsere Politiker, lernt doch mal ein bisschen davon. Wir haben auch Anspruch, darauf eine gute Show geliefert zu kriegen. Die Politik muss natürlich auch hinhauen, aber der Show-Aspekt ist einfach mal nicht zu unterschätzen.
Der Journalist Gideon Rachmann nimmt uns in seinem Buch Welt der Autokraten mit auf eine Reise durch eine autokratisch regierte Welt. Er stellt uns verschiedene Typen vor, wie Duterte, Bolsonaro, Boris Johnson, aber auch den Archetypen Putin. Und wir lernen in dem Buch, wie ideologiefrei diese Ideologen unterwegs sind, wenngleich dieses Buch sehr oft an der Oberfläche nur kratzt.
Was aber auch bedeutet in dieser Welt, in der wir uns nicht so richtig dafür interessieren wollen, von wem werden wir oder die anderen regiert. Hier in diesem Buch werden sie fast wie in einem Adressbuch alle nochmal aufgezählt. Man lernt sie nochmal kennen, auch wie sie miteinander zusammenarbeiten oder eben nicht. Und für alle, die Spaß am Mitdenken haben, ein paar lehrreiche Sachen auch für unsere Nicht-Autokraten stecken dann doch noch drin. Also in der Ansicht eine kleine Lesempfehlung.
Wir sprechen jetzt über Werner Herzog und du siehst Stefan, ich habe gar kein Buch hier liegen.
Wo ist es?
Was ist los? Habe ich es etwa als Liebbuch konsumiert? Ist es zu schwer? Nein. Nun, Werner Herzog, du weißt, es hat diese wunderbare Stimme. Und dann sah ich tatsächlich, er hat seine Memoiren komplett als Hörbuch eingelesen. 15 Stunden. Ich würde das allein schon aufgrund dessen, wie er es liest, empfehlen, sich das anzuhören und nicht zweieinhalbfache Geschwindigkeit oder so was, Stefan, sondern wirklich ganz genießen. Es ist großartig.
Deutsch oder Englisch?
Auf Deutsch hat er es eingelesen. Er wird es vielleicht dann noch auf Englisch irgendwann einlesen. Weiß ich nicht. Er hat manche Sachen auf Englisch eingelesen, habe ich dann bei Audible gefunden. Und er hat diese großartige Stimme für all das. Und es braucht auch diese Stimme, glaube ich, um sich diesen Text wirklich so zu erschließen, der sehr untypisch ist für eine Autobiografie. Und das sagt er auch dann ganz am Anfang schon, wer jetzt erwartet, hier etwas zu erfahren über die Leute, mit denen ich zusammengearbeitet habe, was da am Filmset los war, meine Geschichten, die ich privat hatte. Das wird es hier so gut wie nicht geben. Er sagt, Frauen waren wichtig in seinem Leben, er war, glaube ich, dreimal verheiratet, sehr intensive Beziehungen, oder er war nicht immer verheiratet, ich lege mich nicht fest, er war ja auch mit Eva Mattes kurze Zeit zusammen, ist jetzt seit 25 Jahren mit einer Frau verheiratet, sagte alle Frauen, mit denen er zusammengearbeitet hat und mit denen er auch zusammen war, sie waren selbstständig, stark, schön und intelligent. Und er sagte auch, ohne die Frauen, ohne die Familie, ohne seine Mitarbeiter, wäre er nur ein Schatten seiner selbst. Nun, wir hören Werner Herzog, wie er erst einmal durch seine Kindheit schreitet und selbst noch weiter zurückschreitet, nämlich die Geschichte der Großeltern erzählt, der Eltern erzählt. Wir erleben einen Werner Herzog, der aus einer, wie er es selbst sagt, archaischen Welt stammt. Und es gibt so einen kurzen Abschnitt, wo er mal kurz skizziert, den technischen Fortschritt, den es in der Landwirtschaft gegeben hat. Er hat die Menschen noch mit der Sensor aufs Feld gehen sehen. Und dann hat er mal irgendwo für eine Doku gedreht, da haben die Roboter alles inzwischen gemacht. Da war überhaupt gar kein Mensch mehr da. Und das ist in so kurzer Zeit passiert. Es ist für ihn sehr eigenartig, das zu erleben. Er ist schon einer, der mit dieser Welt fremdelt. Solch radikale Umbrüche, ist es sicher, hat es vorher nie so gegeben. Unsere Kindheit war archaisch. Wir hatten kein fließendes Wasser zu Hause, schreibt er. Und weil er aus dieser Bergwelt stammt, aus dem Süden Deutschlands, was man ja auch seiner Stimme immer noch anhört, weil er so abgeschottet war, hat er das Kino ganz spät kennengelernt. Da war er schon fast 18 Jahre alt oder zumindest war er junglich. Er hatte ganz wenig überhaupt erfahren. Sein erstes Telefonat, glaubte er, hat er wohl geführt, als es um ein Drehbuch ging, ein Skript, das er eingereicht hatte in jungen Jahren. Das heißt, diese technische Welt war ihm vollkommen fremd. Er schreibt dann an einer Stelle, ich wollte immer Außenposten halten, von anderen schon, die von anderen schon verlassen worden sind. Für ihn war es sehr wichtig, sich mit dem auseinanderzusetzen, was es noch geben könnte. Also er ist kein Positivist. Er ist mit 13 Jahren zum Katholizismus konvertiert. 13 Jahre lang zum Katholizismus konvertiert. Er hat sich dann aber auch wieder davon gelöst, weil das doch nicht sein Weg war. Ne, mit 13 ist er dahin und hat das dann einige Jahre gemacht. Er hat aber nie aufgehört, doch zu sagen, dass es irgendwie mehr geben muss. Allerdings sagt er auch, er sei nie esoterisch gewesen. Das wird ja manchmal so ein bisschen so dargestellt. Er sagt, Menschen, die Bäume umarmen, sind mir zutiefst verdächtig. Nun, was erfahren wir sonst außer diesem archaischen Ursprung? Wir erfahren, dass wir es mit einem Menschen zu tun haben, der nicht nur Einzelgänger ist, sondern der auch einen Bruder hat, der auch mit anderen Menschen enge Freundschaften eingehen kann, auch wenn er nur wenige Freunde hat, was aufgrund seines doch sehr umtriebigen Lebens natürlich leicht vorstellbar ist, dass das schwierig ist. Es gibt so etwas wie eine schulische Intelligenz, schreibt Herzog, die ich eindeutig nicht hatte. Da kam er nicht zurecht an der Schule. Er wollte auch nicht Film studieren. Er ist über Umwege an den Film gekommen. Die großen Filme, sagt er, sind mir auch heute nach mehrmaligem Ansehen ein Rätsel. Er kann eigentlich, sagt er, nur aus schlechten Filmen lernen. Und er sagt auch, dass er gar nicht viele Filme sich im Jahr ansieht. Nämlich drei bis vier Filme im Jahr. What? Nicht mehr. Nein.
Einem Quartal?
In einem Jahr. Ja, drei bis vier Filme. Mehr nicht. Er hat auch viele große Meisterwerke nie gesehen. Es ist eine sehr eigenartige Sicht auf die Welt. Und ich glaube, dass wir ihn uns nicht so vorstellen müssen. Er ist ein Intellektueller in einer bestimmten Weise und kennt unglaublich viel. Er spricht über klassische Musik hier, über spanische Chormusik und was weiß ich. Aber er ist niemand, der sagt, ich habe jetzt den Filmkanon und kann jetzt was zu Kubrick sagen und zu Orson Welles und sonst was. Sondern es ist dieser sehr spezielle Blick, vielleicht auch durch seine Sozialisierung, der ihm immer geblieben ist. Als er seine jetzige Frau kennenlernte, um das mal zu beschreiben, war er so sicher, dass sie es ist und sie ist eine Russin, die nach Amerika emigriert ist. Als er sie kennenlernte, sagte er, das muss ich jetzt machen. Und er flog von Europa nach Amerika, komplett ohne Gepäck. Und er wurde dann gefragt, wo denn sein Gepäck sei. In meinen 25 Jahren habe ich das noch nie erlebt. Es sind schon mal Leute, die nur mit Handgepäck kommen. Und dann zeigte Herr Herzog einfach nur seine in der Tasche befindliche Zahnbürste. Das war das Einzige, was er mitgenommen hatte, woraufhin er jetzt erst mal sechs Stunden dann dort ausgefragt wurde, was er da eigentlich vorhabe. Aber man sieht dieses Radikale darin. Und es ist eigentlich ein Buch, das zwar immer wieder von Filmen, die entstanden sind, erzählt, aber wir erfahren eigentlich nie das, was man eigentlich von einem Regisseur erfahren würde. Also das Gegenbuch dazu ist das Interviewbuch von Hitchcock mit Trofobo, wo Hitchcock erzählt, und das haben wir technisch so gemacht. Und da habe ich ganz klar gesagt, wir brauchen da mehrere Kameras und und und. Nichts davon, also technisches spielt hier keine Rolle, auch gar nicht so die große Entwicklung von Stoffen. Die springen ihm an. Er liest irgendwo eine Meldung in der Zeitung und dann wird auch relativ schnell ein Skript geschrieben. Innerhalb von fünf Tagen schreibt er. Und sonst schildert dieses Buch Grenzerfahrungen. Also wie oft er eigentlich dem Tode entkommen ist. Also anders kann man es gar nicht sagen. Es sind unglaubliche Geschichten eigentlich, aber sie scheinen wahr zu sein. Er macht auch so eine große Ernsthaftigkeit, die aber nie in dem Sinne ist, dass er jetzt sagt, ich blase das so mit so einem Pathos auf, sondern es ist tatsächlich so. Also er hat in Nordkorea gedreht, es ging da um Vulkane. Und er hatte da natürlich ganz strenge Anweisungen, was darf da irgendwie gedreht werden. Und dann waren da nordkoreanische Soldaten. Und die waren weit entfernt und die sah er plötzlich. Und da war eine junge Frau und ein junger Mann, also Soldatinnen und Soldat. Und die haben so ein bisschen miteinander geflirtet und haben sich so ein bisschen gestreichelt. Und er schwenkte die Kamera und filmte die. Weil er dachte, unglaublich, das sieht man so nicht. Und dann hat das aber das Personal, das ihn bewacht hat, gesehen. Und dann haben sie gesagt, er soll das löschen. Und dann hat er gesagt, na ja, das ist jetzt digital. Also ich kann das nicht in dem Sinn, ich kann kein Material zerstören für Sie. Ich kann das Ihnen dann... Und dann sagen sie, ja, dann müssen Sie alles zerstören, was Sie jetzt aufgenommen haben. Und dann sagt er, ja, da sind jetzt tagelang Material drauf. Das geht nicht und so. Und dann hat er ihnen gesagt, dass er ihnen verspricht, dass er das niemals zeigen wird. Und dann hat er auch so gesagt, also wenn ich das zeige, dann können Sie machen, was Sie wollen. Also wenn ich ihnen mein Wort gebe, dann ist das so. Und solche Momente gibt es immer wieder. Und das ist sehr faszinierend, wie einfach so das Wort entscheidend ist. Ein paar Anekdoten gibt es dann doch. Es war angedacht, ob nicht Jack Nicholson Fitzcarraldo spielen kann und nicht Klaus Kinski. Aber Jack Nicholson wollte unbedingt in San Diego drehen, denn da spielten die Lakers und da war er großer Fan von. Und er wollte dann immer wieder dahin zurück, dass er alle Spiele sehen kann. Außerdem hatte man die Idee, das in einem botanischen Garten spielen zu lassen, mit einem Miniaturschiff. 20th Century Fox war interessiert daran. Man wollte doch bitte einen guten Dschungel auswählen und nicht so was Gefährliches. Und das ist natürlich dann was, wo Herzog sich einfach dich hat gefallen lassen und ist daraus. Er hat mit Tom Cruise ja getreten in Jack Reacher. Da erzählt er nur ganz kurz, dass Tom Cruise unglaublich freundlich zu ihm war und dass sie sich auch so gut verstanden hat und dass Tom Cruise extra einen Assistenten dabei hat, der ihm alle zwei Stunden ein bisschen Nahrung zuführt. Irgendetwas auf ihn perfekt abgestimmtes mit Kalorienzahlung, was weiß ich. Und als Werner Herzog das sah, und er sagte, er sei auch der Einzige, der sich das trauen würde, dann am Set Tom Cruise so zu reden, war, dass Herzog zu Tom Cruise sagte, ob er dann auch noch einen Psychiater für seine Hunde mit dabei habe. Und Tom Cruise habe aber dann gelacht. Also auf so einer Ebene versteht man sich dann. Es geht natürlich viel um Kinski, um diese Ausraste. Vieles kennt man schon, wenn man sich mit Herzog beschäftigt hat. Eine Sache noch, also wir wissen ja inzwischen, dass Kinski wohl seine Tochter Paula Kinski vergewaltigt hat. Und auch da äußert er sich dazu und sagt, dass Paula Kinski, also Kinskis Tochter, zu Herzog kam und mit ihm sehr lange darüber gesprochen hat. Und dass er auch sagt, er hätte nicht den leisesten Zweifel an diesen Erzählungen. Und doch sei Kinski ein ganz großer Schauspieler und der verteidigt auch die Musik von Richard Wagner. Er sagt so schön, die Musik von Richard Wagner ist so groß, dass wir uns ihr nicht entziehen sollten. Es geht um Fake News, wie er sagt, mit der Kunst muss man schwindeln, um zur Wahrheit zu kommen. Er hat ja diesen tollen Film gemacht über die brennenden Ölfelder in Kuwait, Lektionen in Finsternis. Er hat damals einen Skandal ausgelöst, wie verherrlicht er hier die Apokalypse und diese großen Umweltschäden und alles. Nein, er hat gesagt, ich wollte Bilder finden, die nicht nochmal das sind, was wir in den Abendnachrichten sehen. Und er stellt dem Ganzen ein Zitat von Blaise Pascal voran, der Zusammenbruch der Sternenwelten wird sich, wie auch die Schöpfung, in grandioser Schönheit vollziehen. Und der Witz aber ist, das ist ein Zitat nicht von Blaise Pascal, sondern von Werner Herzog. Und mit sowas spielt er immer wieder. Es ist ein Buch, das man mag, wenn man Herzogs Stimme mag, wenn man diese Art des äxtatischen, das will er eigentlich, das Äxtatische hervorbringen, wenn man das mag, wenn man diese Idee von, ich erzähle eigentlich nichts von mir, er sagt, Selbstreflexion, jedes Kreisen um den eigenen Namen ist mir zutiefst unangenehm. Er sieht sich auch nicht als Workaholic. Drehschluss ist oft schon ab 15 Uhr dann bei ihm. Also er ist niemand, der Nachtdrehs mag. Das dauert alles viel zu lang. Er möchte eigentlich schon auch die schönen Seiten des Lebens genießen. Er ist also nicht einfach so ein nurgetriebener. Es gibt ein sehr schönes Kapitel über Filmprojekte, die er unbedingt gerne auch machen will und die ihn seit Jahren quasi verfolgen. Aber er hat zu viel zu tun, um alles zu machen. Es sind unglaubliche Ideen dabei oder Leute, die er kennengelernt hat. Es ist ein Buch, sicherlich ganz stark für Fans. Aber ich glaube, man kann dieses Buch auch als einen Weg lesen, wie man in einer so verrückten technischen Welt trotzdem und trotz dieser ganzen medialen Einflüsse einen sehr eigenen Blick auf die Dinge sich behält. Und das macht ja seine Filme aus. Und das macht auch sein Schreiben aus und auch sein Lesen.
Ja, ich bin ja nicht so ein Sineast. Ich kenne natürlich Werner Herzog so vom Namen. Ich war dann sehr überrascht, dass er in Mandalorian da plötzlich auftauchte, weil das so eine Serie ist, die ich wirklich nur geguckt habe, weil die Making-ofs interessant waren.
Ja, und er wurde angefragt und hat dann gesagt, sie müssten ihm erst mal das alles erklären, weil er sich mit Star Wars noch nie beschäftigt hat. Er hat ja auch in den Simpsons mehrmals Sprecheräume übernommen. Und als er das erste Mal angefragt wurde, hat er sie gebeten, ob sie mal auf Kassette ein paar Episoden schicken können, dass er sich einen Eindruck macht. Und dann hatten die erst gedacht, der verarscht die. Der wird doch die Simpsons kennen. Und dann sagt er ihnen, er hätte da mal was in der Zeitung, Comics gesehen. Da sagte ich, nee, das ist kein Comic in der Zeitung.
Es ist verrückt. Und so wirkt das ja auch bei Mandalorian. Die haben eben, und das ist ja das, was mich da so interessiert, wie sieht das da aus? Er spielt ja nur indoor. Er sitzt da an so einem Tisch und so weiter. Und ich wusste, außer dem Tisch steht da nichts zum Spielen. Alles andere ist da reinprojiziert. Also er ist da sozusagen alleine mit der Kamera und so und so ein paar Schauspielern. Und ich spiele das dann auch so. So im Sinne von, ach ja, ich wurde angefragt, das hier, weil irgendwie, und dann macht er aber auch voll den Herzog, so was Audiomäßig. So und spielt das dann einfach so durch.
Genau.
Und das ist total faszinierend so zu sehen, weil das eben auch so passt in dieses Outer-Spacige. Das spielt halt irgendwo im Weltraum, wir wissen auch nicht wann, sondern da taucht halt einfach so ein Typ auf. Und der redet halt komisch. Gleichzeitig hat er diese Gravitas dadurch, dass es halt Werner Herzog ist. Auf der anderen Seite begegnet er mir jetzt weniger, aber es rauschte mal so eine Welle an Werbung für seine Masterclass. Irgendwie durch. Der hat ja auch so eine, ich erkläre euch mal, wie Film funktioniert und so.
Ja, aber da macht er ja gar nichts, was man üblicherweise erklärt. Die zwei wichtigsten Dinge, die er Film-Studenten erklärt, ist einmal, wie man Dokumente fälscht, damit man zum Beispiel irgendwo drehen kann. Und wie man Schlösser knackt, um irgendwo reinzukommen.
Ja, also ich war fast mal versucht, mir das anzuklicken. Das kostet ja dann auch immer viel Geld.
Du bist doch so ein Abenteurer, schläfst in Hängematten und so. Eigentlich bist du viel näher an Werner Herzog als ich, würde ich sagen.
Vielleicht gucke ich mir diese Masterclass mal an, weil er scheint ja dann wirklich nur da zu sitzen, während alle anderen plötzlich die Technik rausholen und dann zeigen, wie es geht und so abläufe. Er scheint ja wirklich nur einen Vortrag einfach zu halten, so sitzend, so zu erzählen, wie er das halt sich so vorstellt. Naja, verrückter Typ. Sehr gut, dass er sich hier so investiert und nochmal selber auch seine Texte dann einliest. Wir machen ein ganz sachliches Kapitel auf. Mütterlichen Instinkt ist ein Myth, das Männer kreieren. Chelsea Kenner-Boehm hat darüber geschrieben, weil sie selber gerade ein Buch zum Thema hat. Und in den New York Times hat es dann nochmal groß aufgegriffen, also wirklich groß. Es beginnt natürlich immer bei der Frau, die sich in diesem Falle, die sich nach der Geburt ihre Kinder nicht so gut fühlen, obwohl sie doch sollten. Es gibt doch diesen kleinen normativen Imperativ. Also jetzt ist das Kind da, jetzt bist du doch bestimmt die glücklichste Person aller Zeiten, so wie auch von den Männern ja immer abverlangt wird, wie war die Geburt? Ja super toll und so. Genau, was für ein Quatsch immer. Man ist den ganzen Tag um Sorge und so. Ja, so ein ganz toller Tag. Nee, man ist dann eher froh, wenn die Kinder da sind. Und ich würde wirklich auch sagen, wenn sie dann so zwei Jahre alt sind, dass man auch ein bisschen was mit ihnen anfangen kann. Und dieser Struggle, den viele Frauen nach der Geburt haben, der spielt sogar keine Rolle. Weder innerhalb der Familie, noch in der Gesellschaft. Also auch nicht in der Politik. Und der Status quo ist jetzt einfach, ja, Frauen gebären Kinder und danach sind sie halt automatisch Mütter. Und da muss man sich nicht weiter darum kümmern, denn die wissen ja, wie es geht. Es ist ihnen ja angeboren, sich um ihr Kind zu umsorgen. Also, sagen wir mal, weniger sich, als sich da nur noch ums Kind zu kümmern. Und wo kommt eigentlich die Idee her, dass das die Normalität sein soll? Die Vorstellung geht auf jahrzehntelange Ideengeschichten zurück, schreibt sie, die vor allem Männer geschrieben haben, die nämlich dieses normative Bild entwarfen, um die Realität zu ignorieren und das nannten sie dann Wissenschaft. Und bis heute ist dieser Diskurs über Elternschaft dadurch ziemlich blockiert, wobei wir heute neue Forschung haben, die eben sagt, nee, mütterlichen Instinkt und diese ganzen Autopatismen, die man da so andichtet, die gibt es nicht. So wie man auch in der Sprache irgendwann feststellte, nee, man wird nicht mit einer Grammatik geboren, sondern man lebt halt auf, wie man auflebt. Und es ist dann alles eine Frage der Sozialisation. Damit auch der Politik und auch der eigenen Entscheidung. Also es ist doch alles sehr viel plastischer, als uns immer so dargelegt wird. Und diese Geschichte, die dazu führte, dass wir das Mütterbild von heute haben, geht auch auf zwei Frauen zurück. Allerdings wieder von Männern geschrieben. Eva und die Heilige Maria. Da muss man gar nicht groß ausführen. Da weiß jeder, Eva, also die sozusagen aus der Gnade der Männer heraus. Wir spenden eine Rippe und dann haben wir hier eine Eva und die Heilige Maria.
Und die dann noch sündigt.
Und die dann noch sündigt und sich schuldig macht. Genau, und dann müssen die Männer wieder klären, wie man mit dieser Hose umgeht. Und ihr quasi den Arsch retten und die Heilige Maria, die ja nun einfach zum Kindekommt, wie Frauen zum Kindekommen, das ist halt einfach da. So, das ist schicksalhaft. Es ist göttliche Fügung. Und da gibt es gar nichts weiter zu diskutieren. Es ist, wie es ist. Mit der industriellen Revolution ging es dann aber richtig los, denn die traditionellen Lebensweisen, die eben nicht bedeuteten ein Kind, eine Frau, ein Mann und so, sondern ein beliebiges Velikationsleben, irgendwie am Hofe große Dörfer, also größere Dorfzusammenhänge als die Kernfamilien. Und mit der industriellen Revolution wird dann diese Kernfamilie geboren, indem nämlich Männer, die zum Arbeiten den Hof verlassen, eine Heimat brauchen. Und um die muss sich gekümmert werden. Also hat man den Mann mit Geld ausgestattet, sodass er sich ein Heim finanziert. Alle weiteren inhaltlichen und sachlichen Arbeiten wurden dann der Frau aufgelegt und damit auch die Kindererziehung. Frauen kümmerten sich also um Kinder, blieben damit zu Hause. Und die Ideengeschichte beginnt dann hier auch bei Darwin, der nämlich genau diese biblischen Prinzipien kodifizierte. Frauen sind für die Fürsorge da und Männer machen das mit dieser Konkurrenz, was dann zum biologischen und auch sozialen Fortschritt führt. Herbert Spencer, das Kindergebären verkümmert den Intellekt der Frau. Und damit wurde so eine Grundlage gelegt. Frauen müssen sich entscheiden, entweder für das Kind und diese emotionale Biografie oder eben für die intellektuelle und dann berufliche Biografie. Aber es geht nicht beides. Man muss sich also entscheiden. Die Gesellschaft muss für sie entscheiden. Man will Kinder, also braucht man Frauen, die sich intellektuell nicht weiter engagieren, die also zu Hause sitzen und die Emotionsarbeit leisten. Und William McDougall, das sind alles Soziologen, Psychologen aus dieser Zeit, 100 bis 200 Jahre zurückliegend, hat dann das Kinderkriegen auch als all-absorbing Beschäftigung der Frau bezeichnet. Also die Frau bekommt ein Kind und damit ist sie vollständig beschäftigt. Darüber hinaus, also jenseits der Mutterrolle, bleibt für die Frauen sozusagen nichts übrig. Wir haben es hier mit einem Nullsummenspiel aus wachsendem Intellekt und Elterninstinkt zu tun. Und das Wachstum des einen verkümmert jeweils das andere, was zum einen die Mütter in dieser Rolle hält, oder die Frauen in der Rolle hält, Mütter zu sein, aber auch die Männer befreit davon, sich mit diesen Sachen wie Kindererziehung und so weiter beschäftigen zu müssen, weil die machen ja schon das andere. Also da wurde das einmal so richtig reinprogrammiert in die DNA. Und auch daher erwuchsen dann die ganzen sozialen Sanktionen, die wir ja bis heute haben. Also keine Abtreibung, damit die Frauen emotional nicht verkümmern und die Gesellschaft fortleben kann, keine Scheidung, keine Diskurse über Genderrollen und so weiter. Alles diese biblische Kodifizierung, die sich dann hier in der politischen Ideengeschichte niederschlug, bis dann die ersten Gegenstimmen aufkamen, schon recht früh 1875. Antoinette Brown-Blackwell hat dann prinzipiell mal die Frage aufgeworfen, wenn sich Männer so mit Frauen beschäftigen, sollten nicht dann die Frauen selber nochmal über die Fragestellung und die Antworten nachdenken? Also das ist sozusagen diese Geburt des modernen Feminismus, der sich dann parallel davon fast kriegerische Auseinandersetzungen mit dieser biblischen Kodifizierung, ausgehend von Darwin und so weiter, bis heute ja durchzog. Letta Hollingworth hat damals im American Journal of Sociology geschrieben, Frauen sollten glauben, dass ihnen die Rolle der Mutter so zufällt, wie den Männern die des Soldaten. Und damit war man dann nicht mehr einverstanden, was aber nur bedeutete, dass das ganze zwanzigste Jahrhundert umso mehr verseucht wurde von Psychoanalysten, Psychologen und Ärzten, die nochmal erklärten, dass die mütterliche Liebe für ein Kind so wichtig ist, wie die Vitamine für ihren Körper und dass nur die Mütter diese Liebe geben können. Also man hat die Frauen so richtig in die Pflicht genommen. Marco Vicedo schrieb dann, es gibt eine spezifische Liebe, die nur Mütter bieten können. Und ich finde, diese Argumentation kennen wir ja bis heute. Pflegekräfte müssen halt emotional engagiert arbeiten. Und auch wenn man ihnen weniger bezahlen, machen die es ja trotzdem, weil sie erklären es halt zu ihrer Aufgabe und so weiter. Also da gibt es sozusagen keine politische weitere Aufgabenstellung, denn das wird alles so im 1 zu 1-Verhältnis der Arbeit am Patienten, der Arbeit am Klienten geklärt. Man nimmt sie sozusagen emotional in die Pflicht, einfach das Beste aus einer politisch sehr schlecht gestalteten Situation zu machen.
Was auch bedeutet, wenn das Kind dann nicht so gut gerät, dann ist die Mutter am Ende schuld, weil sie die Liebe nicht gab.
Ganz genau, du sagst es, es ist die Begründung der mütterlichen Schuld und alle daraus erwuchsenen Pflichten gegenüber der Kinder. Und dieser Glaube an einen mütterlichen Instinkt, der diesem zugrunde liegt, hat die ganze Pro-Family-Politik der Konservativen geprägt. Vor allem so, wie wir es heute aus Amerika kennen, dass wir nämlich bis heute keine bezahlte Elternzeit haben, keine Universal Child Care. Und dass all das, was hier politisch unerledigt bleibt, natürlich Domäne der Mutter ist und auch bleiben soll. Richard Nixon hat sich damals, ist ja noch so ein kleiner Aspekt, ganz explizit gegen Sozialpolitik gewährt, weil sie Family-Weakening ist. Wir können den Familien nicht helfen, denn dann denken die Mütter noch, es sei nicht ihre Aufgabe.
Ja, Margaret Thatcher hat ja eine Wahlkampfkampagne gegen alleinerziehende Mütter gemacht. Und dann so CDU-Politikerinnen hatten ja diese These von der mutterlosen Gesellschaft, die uns droht, wenn zu viel Emanzipation da ist.
Genau, so was, das zieht sich durch alle westlichen Gesellschaften. Richard Nixon meinte damals, Zitat, die Familie am rechten Fleck in die Zivilisation einzubetonieren, sei sein Ziel, und das störe jede Art von Sozialpolitik, die irgendwie Entlastung bedeutet. Noch im März 2021, Charlie Sheppard, ein Parlamentarier in Idaho, lehnte Gesetze ab, die es, Zitat, Frauen einfacher macht, Kindererziehung an andere Personen abzugeben. Das ist wirklich unglaublich. Und diese Zertrümmerung des Build Back Better-Programms von Joe Biden, die ja 400 Milliarden für Kinder, also zum einen Halbierung der Kinderarmut, als auch dann Kindergeld und so weiter. Das Kindergeld hat man soweit durchgekriegt, aber diese grundsätzliche Unterstützung, inklusive dann auch Elternzeit und sowas, gibt es ja alles bis heute nicht. Und es steht bis heute diese Grundsatzfrage im Raum, warum sollten Frauen verhüten, wenn Kindererziehung so eine tolle Sache für sie ist? Also so wird ja immer noch diskutiert. Bis hin zu aus Mississippi. Gab es ja diese, naja, wenn Roe vs. Wade abgelehnt wird, dann kann man ja auch gleich mal noch mal über Verhütung nachdenken und die genauso unterbinden. Neu allerdings, und hier dann auch öffnungsstiftend für die Autorin, mal gucken, wie weit es trägt, Social Media erlaubt jetzt relativ vielen Frauen mit ihrer Mütterrolle mal ehrlich umzugehen, also zu dokumentieren, wie man sich körperlich verändert, welchen geistigen Gemütszustand man tatsächlich hat und da eben sozusagen auf eigene Faust sich angreifbar zu machen und gegen diesen Jahrhundertalten Mainstream anzukämpfen.
Da ist ja auch interessant bei diesen Phänomenen, wir haben es ja bei den Influencern auch immer mal wieder gesehen, wie polarisierend auch irgendwelche Aussagen zur Mutterschaft sind oder irgendwelche Bilder. Und es gibt ja von Simone de Beauvoir schon diesen Einwand, es gibt eigentlich nicht so eine weibliche Solidarität. Also Männer bündeln ja immer dann, ja, und dann irgendwie kann dann auch noch Trump mit sie. Und bei Frauen aber gibt es diese Solidarität nicht. Und das wurde auch natürlich ideologisch implementiert, dass man sagt, du bist Mutter und schau her, wenn jemand das nicht perfekt macht, ist man Rabenmutter und so weiter. Und diese Vorwürfe wären natürlich in Social Media noch mal lautstarker vorgebracht. Und deswegen ist es eine sehr zweistreitige Sache. Ich glaube auch, dass es eine andere Form von Diskurs reinbringt. Und zugleich auch wieder neue Formen des Drucks. Also da haben wir natürlich jetzt auch die Girlbosses, die sagen, ja, ich habe ein Kind, aber auch noch eine Karriere. Und ich bin auch noch Influencer und, und, und.
Genau, es läuft hier auf diesen Tenor hinaus. Am Ende, es gibt kein angeborenes Muttergen, was eben bedeutet. Zum einen, es gibt für den Fall, dass man dem weiter nachgehen möchte, dass es so ein ganz elementares, familiäres Anliegen ist, kann der Vater genauso in den Blick rücken. Oder, das ist die zweite Schiene, die ja auch aufgemacht wird, es ist auch alles nur erfunden, ausgedacht und veränderbar. Es ist damit auch ein Domäne der Politik, wie man mit Kindern umgeht. Und ich habe jetzt auch das eine oder andere Radio-Interview zur Alten Republik. Und klar, die stellen natürlich immer diese Fragen zu den Zahlen, Fachkräftemangel usw. Aber so langsam, gerade wenn die sagen, wir haben so ein bisschen mehr als zehn Minuten Zeit, versuche ich dann auch nochmal dieses Familienbild. Wer ist hier zuständig dafür, dass unser Erwerbspotenzial von unten nachwuchs erhält? Wenn wir dann feststellen, 100.000 Schulabgänger ohne Schulabschluss jedes Jahr, wer hat da eigentlich versagt, die Familien oder die Politik? Man kann natürlich immer weiter den Eltern irgendwie die Schuld geben daran, aber wir haben ja eigentlich auch eine Geschichte der Schulpflicht und so. Und wenn die Schule nicht in der Lage ist, Kinder zu einem Abschluss zu befähigen, sondern da irgendwie 15 Prozent pro Jahr einfach mal rausfallen, dann haben wir es hier mit einer politischen Fragestellung zu tun. Und da ist es einfach goldwert, solche Bücher hier zu haben, die das nochmal als Ideengeschichte, also wirklich so diese Narrative nochmal durchgehen, weil wir haben ja vorhin auch darüber gesprochen, wie wichtig so Narrative sind, die einen nochmal da abholen, wo man selber fühlt und sich Sachen wünscht und so. Und da ist das hier doch ein sehr, sehr guter, sehr wichtiger Text.
Identitätspolitik, ein Thema, das wir eigentlich doch nicht mehr hören können. Und so geht's mir schon seit Monaten, ich will fast sagen Jahren. Also ich nehme das nur noch so gerade zu Kenntnis, dass ich weiß, jetzt wird über Vindetou diskutiert, über Leila oder sonst was. Aber mich interessieren diese Fragen genauso wenig wie auch diese ganzen, ja, unglaublich aufgeregten, emotionalisierten Debatten. Also nicht, dass ich nicht die Anlegen von manchen identitätspolitischen Forderungen teile, aber die Art, wie dieser Diskurs geführt wird, ich hatte mitunter den Eindruck, egal mit welcher Position ich mich beschäftige, irgendwie werde ich immer ein bisschen blöder dadurch. Nun kommt der Philosoph Omri Boehm, der ein Buch schreibt mit dem Titel Radikaler Universalismus Jenseits von Identität. Omri Boehm ist bekannt geworden in Deutschland durch sein Buch Israel, eine Utopie, das ich nicht gelesen habe. Und dies ist nun ein Buch, das sich auseinandersetzt mit der Frage, ist der Universalismus zu retten oder ist es nicht eigentlich ganz problematisch, um mal in der Wokensprache zu sprechen, problematic, noch Universalist zu sein, da wir doch wissen, das Erbe der Aufklärung ist zugleich eines von Rassisten, von Frauenfeinden und so weiter und so fort. Und da würde Omri Boehm zunächst einmal sagen, Aufklärung und Universalismus sind nicht dasselbe. Aufklärung ist etwas, was sehr stark am Positivismus angelehnt ist, also an dem auch was Horkheimer und Adorno beschreiben in der Dialektik der Aufklärung. Das heißt, man versucht alles nur wissenschaftlich aufzufassen und versucht dann auch diese wissenschaftlichen Prinzipien zum Beispiel auf den Diskurs zu übertragen. Omri Boehm ist ja auch immer wieder jemand, der sich kritisch mit Habermaß auseinandersetzt. Das findet jetzt hier in dem Buch nicht so statt. Aber mit Rawls und mit Dewey und anderen liberalen Denkern, wo er sagt, ne, die sind auch Aufklärung, ja, und die stammen da aus einer Linie, aber das sind keine Universalisten. Und vielleicht müssen wir da jetzt ein bisschen Klarheit in die Sache einbringen. Es ist nicht ganz leicht, aber ich kann das Buch schon mal jetzt jedem empfehlen und ich kann auch sagen, wenn meine Ausführungen mitunter unklar sein sollten, das Buch ist sehr, sehr klar. Wenn auch nicht ganz einfach, das muss man sagen. Nun, wie müssen wir jetzt also diesen Universalismus begreifen? Martin Luther King ist bekannt für seine I Have a Dream Rede und so weiter und so fort. Aber Martin Luther King war auch ein Universalist, genauso wie Web du Bois. Das ist schon das erste, was wir hier erfahren. Wenn Martin Luther King sagt, für ihn gibt es diesen Traum von Amerika, dass alle Menschen gleich sind, dann ist das eine universalistische Position. Omri Boehm sagt, heute haben wir eigentlich eine Aufkündigung dieser Utopie. Und man sagt, nee, also überhaupt diese Unabhängigkeitserklärung, die wurde ja auch eigentlich von Rassisten geschrieben. Deswegen müssen wir jetzt unsere Identität hervorbringen und diese politisch festigen, ob von rechts oder von links. Aber wir erteilen dem, alle Menschen sind gleich, also der Unabhängigkeitserklärung, eigentlich eine Absage. Die Unabhängigkeitserklärung kannt. Und die Bibel, das würde ich jetzt mal ausspannen, weil das wird dann doch ein bisschen sehr akademisch hier. Das sind, also das Alte Testament, das ist es, worauf sich Omri Boehm bezieht. Er sagt, solche Träume, also dieser Traum von Amerika, gelten Linken wie Rechten gleichermaßen als Illusionen, denn in einem Punkt immerhin sind sie sich einig. Das Problem mit dem universalistischen Projekt der Aufklärung besteht nicht darin, dass es gescheitert ist, sondern dass man es überhaupt versucht hat. Und so wetteifern beide politische Lager darum, den Maßstab des abstrakten Universalismus durch eine konkrete Identität zu ersetzen. Wie die Rechte im Namen traditioneller Werte kämpft, so kämpft die Linke im Namen von Gender und Race. Der universelle Humanismus gilt keiner der beiden Seiten mehr als Grundlage, um ungerechte Gesetze oder diskriminierende Machtstrukturen zu kritisieren und zu verändern. Es wird vielmehr als die Maske wahrgenommen, die es den Herrschenden ermöglicht, die Strukturen der Ausgrenzung und Ausbeutung aufrechtzuerhalten. Und er sagt, damit kommen sich linke und rechte Identitätspolitiker verdächtig nahe. Und deswegen ist sein Ausweg aus dem Ganzen zu sagen, wir müssen zurück zu einem Universalismus. Was ist aber jetzt mit Universalismus gemeint? Universalismus meint tatsächlich, dass es eine Gerechtigkeit gibt. Und das hat ja etwas Metaphysisches und auf das kann man auch nicht verzichten, sagt er. Dass es eine Gerechtigkeit gibt, die absolut ist und dass man sogar dazu bereit ist, Gesetze zu brechen. Also wenn das Gesetz nicht für Gerechtigkeit sorgt, dann ist es kein gerechtes Gesetz. Dann kann man dagegen verstoßen. Oder das heißt auch, dass man sich dem Willen Gottes widersetzt. Er bringt das an einer alter, symmetrischen Geschichte von Abraham und Isaak. Also der Vater soll den Sohn opfern. Und der Vater widerspricht Gott im entscheidenden Moment, weil er sich in diesem Moment auf eine höhere Gerechtigkeit beruft. Eine Gerechtigkeit, die selbst noch über Gott steht. Und wenn Gott dieser Gerechtigkeit nicht gerecht wird, dann hat man das Recht, Gott zu widersprechen. Und Kant, das ist die These von Omri Boehm, nimmt eigentlich da seinen Ausgang und säkularisiert das nur. Und sagt, es gibt eine Gerechtigkeit, das ist so fest als metaphysisches Prinzip anzusehen, dass man nicht zum Beispiel sagen kann, naja, eigentlich geht es jetzt nur gerade um Interessen. Oder eigentlich geht es jetzt nur gerade darum, müssen wir pragmatisch sein. Und er bringt sehr gute Beispiele, also die, naja, ich versuche mal anders weiterzugehen. Und zwar schreibt Omri Boehm, wenn solche Universalisten den aufklärischen Rationalismus gegen die Identitätspolitik verteidigen, also wenn jetzt Liberale sagen, ja wir sind ja irgendwie im Rahmen der Aufklärung, dann gehören sie in der Regel zum positivistischen Zweig der Bewegung, der Vernunft mit Interessen gleichsetzt und für den ein aufgeklärter Universalismus, genau genommen ein Widerspruch in sich ist. Er geht dann auf Richard Rorty ein, auf diese Idee, man muss jetzt vielleicht mal so ein neues Wir finden, so einen neuen Nationalenstolz oder einen Mark Liller, der ja auch die Identitätspolitik der Linken kritisiert. Auch da plädiert man dann für so etwas wie eine Nation, aber er sagt, da tut sich eigentlich ein Abgrund auf, der Abgrund, der immer schon da war, zwischen einer positivistischen Aufklärung und einem Universalismus. Für all jene, die immer noch hoffen, den Universalismus verteidigen zu können, bleibt Kant, schreibt Omri Boehm, der unverzichtbare Denker. Und was lernen wir nun bei Kant? Bei Kant wurde die Idee der Menschheit erstmals als moralischer Begriff definiert. Was Menschen menschlich macht, ist keine natürliche Eigenschaft, sondern ihre Freiheit, ihre Verpflichtung auf moralische Gesetze zu folgen. Weil menschliche Lebewesen offen für die Frage sind, was sie tun sollen, sind sie selbst Subjekte von absoluter Würde. Er geht mehrmals ein auf diesen berühmten Text, was ist Aufklärung? Also, dass man sich aus der selbstverschuldeten Unmündigkeit befreit, ohne dass man einfach nur eine Autorität nachbetet. Er geht das in allen Einzelheiten wirklich grandios durch. Und er sagt dann nur ein Gesetz oder eine Wahrheit, die unabhängig von menschlichen Konventionen ist, ist universell in seinem und ihrem Geltungsbereich und nicht relativ zu den Interessen. Wünschen guten Ideen derjenigen, die über die Macht gebieten, in der menschlichen Gesellschaft Gesetze zu erlassen. Mehr noch, nur ein solches Gesetz ist auch universell in seiner Autorität, statt nur in seinem Geltungsbereich. Es geht über die Digitimität menschlicher Vereinbarungen hinaus, die ja durchaus ungerecht sein können. Und das Besondere, was ich jetzt hier doch entdecke, ist, ich hatte Omri Boehm immer so als so einen liberalen Philosophen abgespeichert, der auch ja gar nicht sagt, ich bin jetzt ein linker Philosoph, aber der hier eigentlich ganz wunderschön darlegt, dass es ein Recht auf Widerstand gibt, dass es sogar ein Recht auf Revolution gibt, dass das alles gerechtfertigt sein kann, wenn man dieser universalistischen Idee die Treue hält. Und wenn wir jetzt mal in unsere aktuellen Debatten über Geopolitik hinzunehmen, dann sehen wir doch ganz viel, die sagen, naja, aber klar, also wir müssen jetzt alles tun, damit wir davon russisch loskommen, aber ja, Aserbaidschan und Katar und so, irgendwo müssen wir auch mal vernünftig sein. Und da sagt er, genau das ist anti-universalistisch, denn man kann nur, also entweder macht man dann wie Karl Schmidt, dann sagt man, eh, von Menschenrechten, der will eh nur betrügen, dann machen wir Großraumtheorie und so weiter. Oder man sagt, nee, dann gilt der Universalismus aber als Universalismus und dann können wir nicht sagen, naja, wir machen es da mal so, mal so. Da ist man in einen Pragmatismus angekommen. Und diesen Pragmatismus schildert er an zwei wunderbaren Beispielen. Ich will das jetzt nur so ein bisschen kursorisch noch abhandeln. Und zwar einmal gibt es die Abolitionisten-Bewegung im 19. Jahrhundert, also die gegen die Sklaverei sind. Da gibt es den Protagonisten Braun, der mit Gewalt vorgeht. Und da sagt dann Lincoln und sagen auch andere, das ist aber, das finden wir jetzt eigentlich doch nicht gut. Also er soll sich jetzt schon mal an die Ordnung halten. Und dann gibt es Thoreau und Emerson, die Philosophen, die sagen, nee, der tritt für die Gerechtigkeit an sich ein. Das geht nur so. Der kann man nicht sagen, wir machen nur ein bisschen Gerechtigkeit. Das wird wunderbar aufgedröselt. Und dann gibt es einen Brief von Bischöfen an Martin Luther King. Und die schreiben ihm, wir sind gegen den Rassismus. Wir müssen dringend diese Gesellschaft reformieren. Es ist alles ganz, ganz furchtbar. Aber wissen Sie, das ist uns jetzt irgendwie, also das ist zu radikal, diese Forderung und das geht nicht. Und Martin Luther King antwortete eigentlich solchen Leuten nie. Und Martin Luther King hat aber dann da geantwortet und hat gesagt, so geht es nicht. Also es heißt dann hier, dass bei Martin Luther King, das war am 10. April 1963, der Verbot, ein Bezirksgericht in Alabama, das Vorhaben schwarzer Aktivisten, einen Protestmarsch in Birmingham gegen die Segregation zu veranstalten. Martin Luther King, der gelobt hatte, die Bürgerrechtsbewegung in die Stadt in Amerika zu bringen, in der die Rassentrennung am vollkommensten durchgeführt wird, kündigte an, er werde sich über die Gerichtsentscheidung hinwegsetzen, führte einen Marsch an und wurde festgenommen. Und dann gab es diesen Brief von geistlichen Pfarrern, ein Rabbiner war auch dabei, die dann sagten, na ja, also wir müssen schon ein bisschen aufpassen. Sie hatten zuvor schon eine Schrift veröffentlicht, an appeal for law and order and common sense. Und dieses sich berufen auf Ordnung, das ist etwas, was antiuniversalistisch ist. Und darüber klärt King sie dann auf. Wenn irgendwo Unrecht geschieht, ist überall die Gerechtigkeit in Gefahr. Das ist die Antwort, die er ihnen schreibt. Und es wird wunderbar dann durchdekliniert anhand dieser Brief und Reden von King. Man muss die auch wirklich noch mal lesen. Das ist also auch so geistreich, warum King eine universalistische Position, genauso wie Brown, eingenommen hat. Und dass daraus eine universalistische Forderung erwächst, die wir auch heute jederzeit wieder scharf machen können, wenn sie irgendwo von Nöten ist. Wenn wir allerdings sagen, nee, das hat ja alles mit der Aufklärung zu tun und das waren Rassisten, dann ist man natürlich vollkommen schief gewickelt. Und er geht dann natürlich auf diesen Kant-Vorwurf, den Vorwurf an Kant ein. Ja, Kant hat sich doch da rassistisch geäußert. Kant hat ja anthropologische Schriften auch veröffentlicht. Und da gibt es dann entsprechendes zu lesen. Dazu sagt Omri Boehm, paradoxerweise trifft die Kraft von Kants abstraktem Begriff der Menschheit im Lichte seiner hässlichen Kommentare über Asiaten, schwarze Menschen und amerikanische Ureinwohner nur umso deutlicher zutage. Weil die Freiheit von anthropologischen und kulturellen Eigenschaften ebenso unabhängig ist wie von der Biologie, ist es auch die menschliche Würde. Ungeachtet dessen, was dieser preußische Philosophie-Professor vor 200 Jahren über Schwarze dachte, hatte er doch keinen Zweifel daran, dass, Zitat, nichts entsetzlicher sein kann, als dass die Handlung eines Menschen unter dem Willen eines anderen stehen soll. Daher kann kein Abscheu natürlicher sein, als den ein Mensch gegen die Knechtschaft hat. Anders gesagt, kann es 200 Jahre alte Anthropologie, als irgendwie relevant für die kantische Moralpholisophie zu betrachten, ist nur aufgrund eines gewollten oder ungewollten Missverständnis seiner wichtigsten Leistung möglich. Demdurch eine metaphysische Abstraktion erreichten ausschluß sämtlicher anthropologischen, historischen, soziologischen, psychologischen, biologischen Fakten vom Nachdenken über die menschliche Würde. Die menschliche Würde nämlich, die ist bei jedem und die ist nicht antastbar. Und die kann man auch nicht so in Verbindung bringen, denk mal nur über deine Privilegchen nach oder überleg mal, wer du bist und so weiter. Das sind alles Sachen, die spielen mit rein. Aber es gibt dieses universalistische Prinzip und das muss, wenn, dann für alle gelten. Und das Tolle ist, dass er, wenn er sich mit den rassistischen Äußerungen von Kant auseinandersetzt, Kant gegen Kant liest. Und das ist ja genau der richtige Umgang. Wir beide ärgern uns ja immer, wenn einfach nur so Autoritätsargumente herangezogen werden. Schon Hegel hat gesagt und dann nicken alle, ja gut, wenn Hegel das gesagt hat, dann muss es aber auch wirklich so sein. Nee, das ist überhaupt nicht Omri Boehm Art, sondern alles, worauf er sich bezieht, was alt ist, ist nur dazu da, dass wir eine Aktualisierung vornehmen und mit diesen Texten so reden, als würden wir gerade miteinander sprechen. Und nicht in einer Weise, hier habe ich noch einen heiligen Text von Kant gefunden, kennt ihr den schon. Und das ist so ein forschendes Herangehen. Es ist ein so herausragendes Buch. Und jetzt habe ich erst wenig vorgestellt und muss jetzt aber auch Schluss machen, damit wir nicht ewig nur über dieses Buch reden. Ich kann es nur jedem empfehlen, sich mit dieser universalistischen Position zu beschäftigen, um auch zu erfahren, was es eigentlich meinte. Als man sagte, man muss das Werk vom Autor trennen. Er geht dann nochmal auf den Tod des Autors ein, bei Roland Barth und Michel Foucault. Macht mal einen ganz schnellen Close Reading zu diesem Roland Barth Essay und sagt nochmal, was das eigentlich für ein Fortschritt ist, wenn wir nicht mehr dem Autor als diese Autorität glauben, sondern wenn wir gucken, stimmt das Argument? Das ist so herausragend, so wunderbar. Ich kann nur empfehlen, dieses Buch zu lesen auf 160 Seiten. Alles zur Identitätspolitik. Und ich würde fast verpflichtend sagen, wann immer noch jemand über Identitätspolitik sprechen will, ob von links oder von rechts. Ich will jetzt hier keine Hufeisen machen, aber egal von welcher Seite, irgendwas kommt. Dann bitte immer nur auf der Grundlage, dass man dieses Buch rezipiert hat. Und dann können wir von da aus nochmal gucken, welche Argumente sich dann noch für das eine oder andere ableiten lassen. Aber wir können auf keinen Fall wieder dahinter irgendwas zurückgehen. Aber das ist die große Gefahr, die Omri Boehm überall sieht, dass man sich von diesem Universalismus, und die Liberalen sind da, die sich jetzt gerade so tun, wir sind ja liberal, die sind da selber in die falsche Richtung abgebogen, schon vor langer Zeit, dass genau dies dazu führt, dass wir dieses Universalistische, und damit aber auch die Menschenwürde verloren gehen lassen. Und deswegen ist das auch ein Weckruf. Auch bei diesen ganzen Fragen der kulturellen Aneignung geht auch noch mal auf dieses berühmte Bild ein, dass eine weiße Macht von einem schwarzen Jungen, der ermordet wurde, ist das kulturelle Aneignung. Da sagt er ja, was machen wir mit Gerhard Richters Birkenau-Zyklus. Er ist eigentlich nie provokativ, in dem Sinne, dass er jetzt nie polemisch ist. Er ist schon provokativ, aber nie polemisch. Aber er sagt dann auch, naja, man könnte das auf Richters Bilder über Birkenau genauso machen. Und wie wollen wir denn eigentlich noch wissen, was wir in der Kunst darstellen? Es muss doch tatsächlich dazu gehen. Er sagt, das Problem an dieser Logik besteht darin, dass alles, was von jemandem besessen werden kann, von jemand anderen besessen werden kann. Das ist im Wesentlichen eine Frage des Preises. Nur ein unzulängliches Verständnis menschlichen Leids kann zu der instrumentellen Annahme führen, dass ich, weil ich jüdisch bin, ein Recht darauf habe, das jüdische Leid zu kennen und zu besitzen und zu verwenden. Allerdings impliziert die Tatsache, dass kein menschlicher Schmerz jemanden des Eigentums sein kann, nicht, dass er nicht Gegenstand der Kunst sein kann. Im Gegenteil, er muss in künstlerischem Schaffen verarbeitet werden, in diesem einzigen Medium menschlichen Handels, dem es möglich ist, die vorherrschende Reduktion des Denkens auf eine instrumentelle Verwendung zu überwinden. Und damit will ich einfach schließen und ausdrücklich sagen, das ist jetzt mal ein richtiger Debattenbeitrag.
Leseempfehlung immer sehr gut, vor allem an die progressiven linken aufgeklärten Seiten. Denn was wir ja immer wieder beobachten und das die Menschenwörter Artikel 1 und so weiter, da geht ja auch eine Geschichte voraus, die uns lehrt, ja das Pendeln muss schon ganz schön ausschlagen, um dann wieder zurück zu pendeln. Und dann stellt man so fest, da ist irgendwo die Mitte. Okay, dann schreiben wir das jetzt mal fest, weil das Pendeln pendelt ganz schön viel. Und diese Idee von, es muss dann wirklich erst ein Zweiter Weltkrieg stattfinden, um dann mal einen Artikel 1 wirklich festzuschreiben. Und nicht nur das so mitlaufen zu lassen als Idee und so weiter, sondern darauf, dass es jetzt alle verpflichtet. Das kennt man ja auch im Kleinen, man muss immer erst mal übertreiben. Es muss erst eine Überkompensation sozusagen angestrebt werden, um sich dann irgendwo in der Mitte zu verfangen. Das ist der ganz normale Verhandlungs-Kram zum Beispiel. Man geht erst mal mit einer 5-prozentigen Forderung rein und einigt sich dann noch zweieinhalb und so. Also es begegnet einem immer wieder. Und hier dann auch, wenn man und häufiger höre ich jetzt immer wieder solche Anklagen gegen das Zu-Woke beispielsweise, es finden Konferenzen statt und es gibt Regeln dafür, wie die Bühnen besetzt werden sollen. Weil man dann immer vermutet, das ist eine dieser Überkompensation. Hier schlägt das Pendel zu weit aus. Und es fällt ganz schwer anzuerkennen, dass das Pendel erst mal zu weit ausschlagen muss. Und das wird jetzt erst mal durch zehn Jahre. Nee, hier müssen Frauen auf die Bühne und hier müssen People of Color auf die Bühne und hier müssen auch verschiedene soziale Hintergründe auf die Bühne, um das dann zum Normalfall zu machen. Aber es muss erst mal sozusagen über ausschlagen, was dann wieder der rechten Seite das Material liefert, dagegen anzuwettern, dass ja das Pendel gerade zu. Aber sonst kommt man da nicht weiter.
Aber würdest du sagen, dass diese Pendel-Bewegung so zwingend sein muss? Also klar, du hast jetzt Beispiele benannt, wo einem das sofort einfällt. Und das Grundgesetz ist ein deutliches Zeichen dafür. Andererseits kann man auch sagen, da hat das Pendel die eine Seite sehr ausgeschlagen, die andere dann nicht. Und da hat man sich gleich in der Mitte geeilt. Ich glaube, das Problem ist ja vielleicht eher zu erkennen, dass wenn ich Identitätspolitik mache in dem Sinn, dass ich sage, ich will meine Interessen durchsetzen, dann bin ich auf einem anderen Terrain als auf dem Terrain, ich will, dass alle Menschen gleich sind und behandelt werden. Und wenn man jetzt zurückgeht auf die amerikanische Unabhängigkeitserklärung oder zu Kant und deutlich macht, das Argument da drin, wie Autorität zu verstehen ist und dass es gerechtfertigt ist, sich jede Autorität zu widersetzen, die die Gerechtigkeit nicht ermöglicht bzw. ungerecht ist, das ist ja etwas, was eigentlich das sein muss, worüber wir zu diskutieren haben. Denn alles andere ist dann irgendwie, dann kann das am Ende so, ich will auch mal stattfinden oder so. Ich hätte gerne, guten Tag, ich hätte gerne eine Fernsehsendung oder so was. Und wir sind eigentlich jetzt gerade an einem Punkt dran, wo immer gefragt wird, wer sagt etwas. Und das ist so erstaunlich, dass Adorno schon darauf hingewiesen hatte, also es wird hier auch noch mal zitiert, dass es eigentlich nichts fürchterlicheres gibt, wenn Leute nicht ein Argument machen, sondern sagen, ich als. Und das ist für mich auch ganz schwer auszuhalten. Also es mag das in irgendwelchen Situationen mal geben, wo das machbar sein kann, aber diese ich als Mann, ich als so. Diese Argumentation führt uns am Ende zu einem permanenten Kulturkampf. Das geht dann bis hin zum Apfel von Lestras, aber führt uns nie zu einem Universalismus, wo man tatsächlich eine Gleichheit etablieren will. Sondern dann ist nur die Frage, wer, der lauter ich als ruft, wird sich am Ende durchsetzen.
Genau und deswegen wissen wir, wie die Diskussionen geführt werden. Und wir kennen die Resultate, beispielsweise bei Artikel 1 Grundgesetz, Würde des Menschen. Wir können jetzt einfach, so wie du es eben gesagt hast, irgendwer sagt halt etwas, spricht vielleicht nicht mal in eigener Anwaltschaft oder wie auch immer. Aber wer ist der Autor von Artikel 1? Die Geschichte selbst. So, jeder kann sich dazu verhalten. Es gibt keinen Autor von Artikel 1. Man kann nicht einfach politisch aufstehen und sagen, ich fordere eine Abkehr von Artikel 1, weil dann wendet man sich gegen die Geschichte als Autor selbst, die uns allen aufgezwungen hat, diesen Universalismus, der da drinsteckt, anzuerkennen. Und ich finde es zum Beispiel jetzt gerade wahnsinnig bescheuert, dass wir es nicht geschafft haben, zu sagen, ne, wir machen die Atomkraftwerke nicht an. Wisst ihr warum? Wegen der Geschichte. Nicht, weil die Grünen das ausschalten wollen. Und deswegen die FDP sagt, na dann sind wir aber dafür, dass die bleiben. Also dieses identispolitische, wer hat es gesagt? Also wettern wir dagegen.
Und auch diese Idee der, jetzt sind wir mal vernünftig und machen das. Ne, es ist an sich widerspricht, das länger Anlassen von Atomkraftwerken dem Prinzip der grundlegenden existenziellen Sicherheit. Und damit ist die Frage beantwortet.
Wir haben es technisch nicht unter Kontrolle. Das zeigt uns Fukushima. Kein anderes Land geht so diszipliniert mit Atomkraftwerken und Technologie allgemein und wie Japan. Und wir in Europa, die wir nicht mal die Technik richtig unter Kontrolle haben, haben zusätzlich noch, ach so, da ist gerade ein Krieg, aber da kann man keine Rücksicht nehmen auf Atomkraftwerke, sondern das ist jetzt Spielmasse in sowas. Also auch die sozialen Komponenten haben wir nicht unter Kontrolle. Und ich finde, wir sind eigentlich, also ich hätte gedacht, wir sind bei der Atomkraft auf dem Universalismus-Level angekommen, dass wir sagen, die Geschichte sagt uns, nutzt kein Atomkraftwerke, denn das ist für niemanden gut, wenn es explodiert. Die Wolke fragt dann nicht, wen hast du zuletzt gewählt, und dann verschone ich dich oder sowas, ja. Da ist kein particulares Verteilen von Leid irgendwie drin, sondern das ist universalistisch. Und trotzdem kriegen wir es da auch nicht hin. Also da sieht man immer wieder, wo die Grenzen dann sind.
Wenn du es gerade ansprichst, dann will ich noch gerade diesen einen Aspekt zum Liberalismus, weil das vielleicht eben ein bisschen wirr wirkte, machen. Denn was deutlich wird bei Omri Boehm ist, dass er zeigt, wie Rawls und Dewey eigentlich nicht eine universalistische Position vertreten, zwar sagen die Aufklärung ja und Wissenschaft ja und all das, aber sie wollen eigentlich eine Politik des Machbaren. Und es wird dann hier ein längerer Ausdruck von Rorty zitiert, wo er dann sagt, wir müssen noch gucken, was ist denn machbar? Können wir den Unterschichten Kindern eigentlich helfen? Na ja, gut, machbar ist es vielleicht nicht, weil wir ja viele Leute haben, die keine höheren Steuern wollen. Und wenn man in diesem Modus denkt, dann denkt man anti-universalistisch. Und man kann auch sagen, wollen wir eigentlich mit den Atom-Kaffekten, ja gut, dann sonst wird es vielleicht noch teurer. Oder lasst mir mal die da laufen. Man sagt ja, mit diesem Satz, also ich bringe jetzt dieses Zitat nicht mehr, zeigt die unionistische Demokratie, damit meint er also auch bis hin zu Lincoln und so, von Holmes bis Rawls, ihr war das Gesicht, so wenig wie die unionisten Menschenleben, Geld und das Gedeihen des amerikanischen Marktes geopfert hätten, um die Schwarzen zu emanzipieren, die nach ihrem gesunden Menschenverstand und ihrer Intuition ohnehin minderwertig waren, können wir Liberale, so nennt Omri Boehm sie, eine Verpflichtung erkennen, ihr Leben zu ändern, um schwarze Kinder zu retten. Wenn die Wahrheit einst über dem Konsens stand, also die Wahrheit einst über dem Konsens stand und so die amerikanische Mittelschicht in die Pflicht nahm, dann erscheint sie hier als die absolutistische Vorstellung, die der Liberalismus abschaffte. Und deswegen steht jetzt der Konsens über der Wahrheit und der Konsens ist jetzt gerade, ja gut, dann doch wohl noch ein bisschen Atomkraft. Und das können wir auf uns viele Dinge übertragen.
Genau, sehr gut. Bleiben wir auf dieser Dimension, wechseln wir aber die Richtung. Ultra-partikularistisch sind diejenigen, die einfach nur noch für sich selbst eine Rettung suchen und denen alles andere egal ist. In diesem Falle, die Andichtung fällt nicht schwer, sind das Millionäre und Milliardäre, die die Mittel haben, genauso zu handeln. Und der publizistische Tausend-Sasser Douglas Rushkoff hat für den Guardian aufgeschrieben, wie es ist, eingeladen zu werden. Von so Typen, die einen sagen, kommen sie mal da und dahin, wir haben Fragen, können sie uns einen Vortrag halten? Und dann fliegt er dahin, steigt in ein Auto, wird dahin gefahren drei Stunden lang und wundert sich, hey, wieso treffen die sich hier? Das ist doch voll schwer zu erreichen. Auf dem letzten Meter ist natürlich neben der Straße noch ein Runway für die Privatjets, die fliegen also bis ins Gebirge und stehen dann da aufgereiht und sind bereit, ihren Vortrag zu empfangen. Interessieren sich dann aber gar nicht dafür, was Roschkoff zu sagen hat, sondern wollen im Grunde nur ihre Fragen loswerden und erzählt sie dann auf Bitcoin oder Ethereum, Virtual Reality oder Augmented Reality, Neuseeland oder Alaska, also dieser ganze Kram. Was ist eigentlich bedrohlicher, Global Warming oder dass doch jemand eine biologische Waffe entwickelt? Und dann taucht das Gespräch dann sozusagen in die Fragen ab, die die eigentlich interessieren. Nach relativ kurzer Zeit haben wir dann nur noch darüber gesprochen, wie behalte ich Autorität über meine Sicherheitspersonal nach dem Event? Warte mal, was ist nach dem Event?
Nicht, dass da jemand Stiften geht vom Personal.
Genau, die haben einfach im Kopf so ein Event, ein Tag X, ab dem sie wissen, es könnte jetzt die Atmosphäre zerstört sein oder das Geld nichts mehr wert oder wie auch immer, es gibt keinen Strom mehr. Wie sage ich dann meinen Leuten, dass sie weiter für mich arbeiten sollen und sich nicht selber einen Führer suchen? Immerhin haben die die Muskeln und die Waffen.
Wie vom Binde verweht, da ist das ja in dem Film, da gehen die dann auch verlustig.
Genau, da geht man schnell mal stiften. Wie bezahlt man Sicherheitsleute, wenn selbst Krypto funktionslos geworden ist? Da sind dann so Fragen, die da gestellt werden. Da sieht man schon, die stehen echt unter Druck. Werte zu verteidigen, ist ganz schön schwer. Das kann ein schlaflose Nächte breiten. Urschkopf plädiert dann noch so ein bisschen dafür, vielleicht versuchen wir es mit Vorsorge. Wir machen einfach eine bessere Politik, um den Event vielleicht in der Wahrscheinlichkeit so ein bisschen zu dimmen. Das halten die aber alles für Hippie-Philosophie. Die wollen jetzt wissen, was ist, wenn. Die bereiten sich einfach, nachdem sie die ganze Welt, er sagt natürlich nicht über wen er hier spricht, wen er da getroffen hat, aber nachdem sie die Welt in die digitale Zukunft geführt haben, mit diesem ganzen Gemeinschaftsblabla und so weiter, suchen die jetzt selber ihren exklusiven Exit und bereiten das materiell und ideell vor. Die bauen sich solche Bunker, Flughäfen, Flugzeuge und holen sich halt solche Vorträge und solche Experten ran, die dann irgendwie noch mal so ein bisschen inspirativ zur Seite springen können. Und deren Ziel ist, sich vor allen anderen in Sicherheit zu bringen. Und er zählt dann so ein bisschen die populären Sachen auf. Also Bezos will ins All, Thiel will nach Neuseeland, Zuckerberg will ins Metaverse. Also da sieht man auch, okay, er geht ein bisschen spielerisch hier mit den Sachen um, die er da erlebt hat. Und die im Silicon Valley sind jetzt alle so ein Eskapismus zum Opfer gefallen, den sie das Mindset nennen. Also die reden ganz explizit über ihren Mindset. Wie schaffen wir es durch die Katastrophe? Wir haben es mit einem grauen Schwan zu tun. Also es ist kein schwarzer Schwan, der unvorbereitet kommt, sondern es ist ein grauer Schwan. Wir wissen, es ist eine Katastrophe und sie kommt auch. Also sie ist sozusagen vorhersehbar, aber die Details kennen wir noch nicht. Man hat jetzt den grauen Schwan.
Und das kann alles sein, vom Atomkrieg bis hin zum Klima, Tsunami, was auch immer.
Es kann alles sein und deswegen machen sie jetzt SWOT-Analysen, S-W-O-T, Strength, Weakness, Opportunities, Threats. Also sie gucken sich die Sachlage an und machen dann so Balkendiagramme irgendwie, oder so Linendiagramme, wo sie sich so reinmalen, in welchen Dimensionen hier irgendwie entweder Gefahr oder Hilfe verspricht und wie auch immer.
Ich las kürzlich von Querdenkern, dass da einige Deutschland verlassen und nach Ungarn gehen, in der Hoffnung, dass sie dort von Orban gut im Ausnahmezustand regiert werden. Und da werden dann hier Häuser verkauft, also Menschen, die normal bürgerlich, kleinbürgerlich gelebt haben mit dem Häuschen, werden verkauft und man geht nach Ungarn, bildet da irgendwelche Kolonien, fällt natürlich wahrscheinlich auf irgendwelche Immobilienhaie dort hinein, was auch immer, aber glaubt, dass hier sozusagen die Zelte schnellstens abgebrochen werden müssen, damit man sich noch flüchten kann dann und in Ungarn bei Orbán in Sicherheit sich wendet. Also das ist die eine Tendenz, die wir haben. Die andere Tendenz, von der ich jetzt auch vermehrt höre, weil ich ja doch immer noch so ein bisschen gucke, was machen meine lieben Influencer. Es ist auch da ja diese ganz starke Ausstiegsfantasie, sich erstmal vor Steuern und so weiter zu retten und dann auch so in Sicherheit zu sein vor allem. Und viele Influencer steigen ja, oder auch Streamer gerade, da kann man es besonders gut auch machen, die sich dann an irgendwelchen komischen Orten der Welt inzwischen aufhalten, die also auch Deutschland verlassen haben. Und ich glaube, es hat nicht nur so eine steuerliche Sache, sondern auch so ein apokalyptisches, ich sitze jetzt hier nicht mehr in meinem Keller in Bonn, sondern plötzlich irgendwo am Ende der Welt und versuche mich da zu vergraben und mache aber auch noch ein Krypto, damit ich da sicher bin. Also ich glaube, das ist in gewisser Weise nicht nur bei den Superreichen dann zu finden.
Ja, dieses Prepper-Phänomen gibt es ja überall. Du musst dich ja nur einmal auf eine Wandertour vorbereiten, wo du eine Nacht bei YouTube schon alles voll hast. Von Leuten, die sagen, das kann man auch einen Monat lang so machen. Also da bist du ganz nah dran an der Vorstellung kleiner Werkzeuge, die du da noch brauchst. Wie macht man Feuer und so? Und ja, im großen Rahmen, er ist ja auch noch mal zu diesen Anbietern von so verschiedenen, es sind ja nicht nur Bunker, sondern ein bisschen zu Farmen. Richtig autarkes Leben wird da versprochen und ja, man kann sich dann einfach, er schaut sich so Bunker an. Es geht bei 40.000 Dollar los, kriegst du dann so ein Wohnzimmer unter der Erde, bis hin zu großen Oasen, die dir dann nochmal in Bildschirme und so weiter Außenwelt versprechen, die aber schon gar nicht mehr da ist. Dann kommt ein Pool, dann kommt eine Wand mit Fenstern und draußen wird den dann vorgegaukelt, sei noch.
Ja, wie in Swirled Green, da gibt es das auch. Da gibt es auch eine riesige Leinwand und da bekommt der Alte vorm Sterben nochmal die Natur gezeigt.
Genau, da musst du dann so ein paar Millionen investieren, aber sowas gibt es dann auch maßgeschneidert. Also das ist grenzenloser Markt mittlerweile. Oder auch Schiffe auf einer See, auf der Jacht leben. Ich würde mal sagen, wir schließen den Text ab mit dem Hinweis, es sind alle bekloppt. Er sagt jedenfalls auch ganz klar, der Ruschkopf, das ist hier alles Träumerei. Die glauben, sie hätten noch etwas in der Hand, dass sie nach dem Event führt, aber eigentlich wissen sie auch, der Event wird, wenn er so stattfindet, wie er stattfindet, einfach alles zerstören und sie auch. Sie werden sich nur nicht vorwerfen können, sie hätten nicht alles versucht nochmal, aber es wird sie auch ereilen.
Wir gehen mal schnell nach Frankreich, reden kurz über Corona. Annika Jörös schreibt in der Zeit ein Artikel über Corona in Frankreich, der so beginnt. Wer in diesen Tagen von Frankreich nach Deutschland pendelt, wird bis Straßburg in einem Zug mit unverdeckten Gesichtern sitzen. Und nach der Durchsage des Schaffners in der deutschen Grenzstadt Kehl hingegen kramen die Passagiere meist hektisch nach ihren FFP2-Masken. Die Corona-Regeln sind in beiden Nachbarländern wieder einmal unterschiedlich. Frankreich hat Ende Juli den selbst erklärten Ausnahmezustand beendet und damit auch alle Maßnahmen abgeschafft. Ein Impf- und Genesennachweis ist nirgendwo mehr erforderlich. Und wenn die Schülerinnen und Schüler in dieser Woche wieder zum Unterricht gehen, wird niemand mehr eine Maske tragen, ebenso wenig wie im ÖPNV oder in den Fernzügen. Wir hatten ja gerade die Debatte hier, hier Flugzeuge, da macht man jetzt eine Sonderregelung. Da gibt es keine FFP2-Maskenpflicht, dann wie Lauterbach das wollte. Das ist ein bisschen absurd. Nun war ja Macron für seine harte Hand während der Corona-Pandemie bekannt. Ausgangssperren ab 18 Uhr, drakonische Strafen. Es wurde immer autoritärer. Und inzwischen aber ist es so, dass Macron beschlossen hat, Corona für beendet zu erklären. Es gibt zwar immer noch die Empfehlung, in Büros und Schulgebäuden zu lüften, aber sonst lebt es sich heute in Frankreich so wie vor der Pandemie. Tatsächlich hat sich die Stimmung auch unter den Wissenschaftlern gewandelt. Da war zum Beispiel der zum Expertenrat gehörende Vorsitzende Jean-François de Freyzy, der hat sich kritisch jetzt geäußert. Und da heißt es, natürlich bedauere ich es vieles, sagt der Immunologe im Radio-Interview. Wir haben manchmal die Gesundheit über die Menschlichkeit gestellt. Das ist wirklich ein interessanter Satz. Über die folgenreichen Entscheidungen für Schulen und Altenheime etwa hätten wir mit den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern sprechen müssen. Aber das habe die Politik nicht gewollt, sagt er. Und damit ist dann natürlich Macron gemeint, der jetzt die Pandemie für beendet erklärt hat. Delphresy sagt, also unter auch Macron sagt es auch, ein Satz, den wir beide glaube ich kennen, wir müssen mit dem Virus leben. Das sagen sie jetzt. Und ja, es ist natürlich die Aufgabe des Staates, heißt hier nochmal für eine gesunde Bevölkerung und so was zu sorgen. All das ist richtig. Aber es gilt jetzt eigentlich, und das wird hier von USK gemacht, die Kliniken in den Blick zu nehmen. Kleinere Kliniken müssen wieder geöffnet werden. Es kann nicht sein, dass das alles kaputtgespart wird. Also auch da sind Antworten fällig. Antworten, die aber auch Lauterbach nicht uns gibt. Und ich finde, will das einfach, will gar nicht mehr dazu sagen. Man kann den Artikel jetzt noch ein bisschen länger, kann man nachlesen, wir verlinken das ja immer. Und ich will damit nur deutlich machen, wir haben es hier mit einem Land zu tun, wo Gideon Rachmann sagt, also Deutschland und Frankreich, da ist noch nicht alles irre. Und da kann man sich ja mal Gedanken drüber machen über den deutschen Sonderweg. Und dabei belassen wir es. Mehr sage ich jetzt nicht.
Sehr gut. Bleiben wir bei einem Gesundheitsthema. Bei Weiß schreibt Johann Marc Beaton, wie auch immer man es ausspricht, zur Frage. Wir haben Leute, die aus Überzeugung barfuß laufen, gefragt, warum sie das tun. Du kennst wahrscheinlich nie die Verlegenheit, barfuß zu laufen, also zu Hause, auf sicherem Terrain.
Ich kenne natürlich noch die Schäfer. Kennst du noch die Schäfer? Die Volksmusiktruppe, die sind immer barfuß aufgetreten. Und ich glaube auch Harpo trat immer barfuß aus, oder? Aber sonst gehe ich mit Schuhen und immer, möchte ich auch betonen, geschlossene Schuhe.
Geschlossene Schuhe. Es stellt sich ja diese Frage auch vielleicht andersrum. Wir haben Leute, die aus Überzeugung niemals barfuß laufen, gefragt, warum. Hätte man auch drüber schreiben können. In diesem Falle, seit Jahrtausenden tragen Menschen Schuhe, aber in letzter Zeit scheint es wieder großes Interesse an barfuß laufen zu geben. Und jetzt ist ja auch immer so eine Subfrage. Erstens ist es ein Lifestyle, zweitens wie wir da begründet. Schützen jetzt diejenigen ihre Füße mehr, die barfuß laufen oder nicht? Und vor was? Geht es um Scherben oder um den Knochenwuchs oder wie auch immer? Man kann sie an alle Richtungen dehnen. Sie kommen ja auf jemanden zurück. Daniel Liebermann, ein Evolutionsbiologe, der eine Untersuchung gemacht hat. Er hat fünf verschiedene Versuchsgruppen in Amerika und Kenia, um sie nämlich zu finden. Gewohnheitsmäßige Barfußläufer, barfuß aufgewachsen, aber jetzt in gedämpften Schulen. Läufer, die mit Schuhen aufwuchsen, aber jetzt überwiegend barfuß laufen oder in minimalistischen Schuhen. Und dann noch mal zwei Untergruppen Jugendliche, die entweder noch nie Schuhe getragen haben oder schon ihr ganzes Leben. Also sozusagen einmal, deswegen Amerika und Kenia. Alles, ich kann jetzt sagen, versucht selber noch mal in diesem Text etwas zu finden, was euch wirklich hilft bei der Frage, die mich sehr beschäftigt. Wieso beschäftigt die dich?
Hast du schon mal jetzt probiert, barfuß zu gehen?
Und wie gestaltet sich das denn? Also nicht ganz barfuß, aber barfuß Schuhe. Es gibt ja so welche, die sich wirklich nur wie eine Socke drüberlegen und dir den ganzen Untergrund trotzdem zur Verfügung stellen. Aber ich habe jetzt gemerkt, seitdem ich jetzt immer klettern gehe im Sinne von Bouldern, wurde ja so frei bis 4,50 Meter Höhe. Und es sind ja schon zum einen sehr komische Körperbewegungen. Zum anderen stellt man aber fest, die Griffe der Hand, also ich habe halt so Schreibtishtäterhände. Ich hänge fünf Minuten an solchen Boulder-Dingern und danach tut mir alles weh. Man kann jetzt mit Schalk und so weiter ein bisschen was machen und danach die Hände eincremen. Aber wir haben uns ausführlich darüber informiert, man kommt nicht drum herum. Es gibt keinen Shortcut. Die Hand muss einmal an diese Steine gewöhnt werden. Da nützen keine Handschuhe oder irgendwelche Lappen, die man im Fitnessstudio nochmal dazwischen hängt, die silikonmäßig und so. Das gibt es alles nicht. Wer klettern will, braucht dafür seine Hände, wie sie ihm die Natur gegeben hat. Und wir haben nun diese Schreibtestäterhände, sind nicht die, die uns die Natur gegeben hat, sondern die können eigentlich mehr. Und dieses Barfußlaufen ist auch so ein bisschen. Ich weiß von sehr vielen, die sehr viel laufen, dass sie dann auch, wenn sie nicht laufen, Barfußschuhe tragen, um den Fuß genau die Widerstände, die ihm die Natur gibt, auszuliefern, weil das einfach Kräftigung bedeutet. Anstatt so gepolstert durch die Welt zu gehen und dann aber nach 30 Jahren irgendwie festzustellen, das Sitzen ist ja ganz schön anstrengend, plötzlich tut der Rücken weh, weil man eben von Fuß aufwärts sozusagen seinen Körper nicht unter Kontrolle hatte. Und da stecken ganz viele Fragestellungen so drin, medizinisch, aber eben auch so, was Gefühl angeht. Und die werden hier so beantwortet. Es ist einfach ein Text, der nochmal den Fokus darauf legt. Wahrscheinlich lohnt es sich, diese Originalstudie dann von dem Daniel Liebermann zu lesen. Aber ich fand dieses Setting, überhaupt mal solche Kontrollgruppen aufzumachen, gar nicht so uninteressant, weil es gibt natürlich auch wieder diese Lifestyle-Trends heute. Dass irgendwelche 28-Jährigen dann, nur weil du barfuß läufst, heißt das nicht, dass du deine Füße aufgegeben hast, sondern genau das Gegenteil. Rückkehr zum Fuß, zur Natur, darüber, dass man auf Zivilisationsfortschritte einfach verzichtet.
Aber man geht ja hauptsächlich im urbanen Raum dann. Also wenn ich mir das jetzt vorstelle, man geht die Haustür raus und dann ist man auf Bürgersteigen unterwegs und auf Straßen und geht in eine Shopping-Mall vielleicht rein. Und das dann barfuß?
Ja, Füßvorsorge sieht hier so aus. Ich säuber meine Füße täglich mit einer Bürste und einem Bimmstein und ich achte darauf, nicht in Müll oder Glas zu treten. Barfuß zu leben, lehrt dich bewusster darauf zu achten, wohin du trittst. Und es sind hier einige, die dann reisebloggermäßig barfuß unterwegs sind und hier dann auch davon berichten, wie es ist in so Ländern, Brasilien und so weiter, wo man nicht so sehr auf die Straße achtet und auch sehr viel biologischer Abfall von den Tieren und so weiter rumliegt, da dann trotzdem durchzukommen. Ich würde es auch nicht übertreiben. Ich würde auch hier nicht barfuß laufen, sondern immer mit barfuß Schuhen, die aber dann wieder eben bedeuten, dass man dann doch zumindest was Muskel, Sehnen, Hautgefühlslagen angeht, da einfach anders unterwegs ist, als eben durchgepämpert auf besohlt. Du guckst sehr skeptisch, aber es gibt Menschen, die…
Mein Füße sind sehr wichtig für die Gesundheit. Aber ich gehe regelmäßig zur Fußpflege.
Ja, also hier, ich habe bemerkt, dass das Tragen von Schuhen im Körper Ungleichgewichte erzeugt. Sagt sie, Schuhe hindern dein Nervensystem daran, optimal zu arbeiten. Und ein Nervensystem ist ja eine Schifre für alles. Die meisten Menschen, mit denen wir für diesen Artikel gesprochen haben, sagen allerdings, dass sie hin und wieder auch Schuhe tragen. Also niemand ist hier ganz ideologisch orthodox dabei. Aber ein Hinweis ist natürlich noch zu machen. Das wird eh nochmal Thema. Es ist nur für schlanke Menschen gedacht. Menschen mit Übergewicht können nicht barfuß gehen, ohne ihre Fußgelenke zu schädigen. Auch das bringt einen wieder zur Natur, sagt hier ein 37-jähriger, erfahrener Barfußläufer. Na ja, es gibt die neuen Befürworter des Barfußlaufens, die damit Körperprobleme ganzheitlich angehen. Es geht dann nicht nur um die Füße und so weiter, es geht um ein neues Körperbewusstsein, das man hier hervorruft. Und außerdem, und das ist dann hier so ein letztes Zitat aus dem Text, mit dem man auch schließt, die Schuhe isolieren dich von Signalen des Bodens, die dem zentralen Nervensystem übermittelt werden sollen. Sie führen dich also weg von der Natur, weg von der Welt, in der du steckst. Immer mal ein bisschen barfuß laufen. Ich glaube, es hat was. Ich habe jedenfalls barfuß Schuhe, die ich zuletzt zu wenig getragen habe. Ich habe mich gestern wieder daran erinnert, dass ich sie habe.
Und jetzt muss ich... Wie sehen die aus?
Ich kann sie dir gleich zeigen.
Transparente Socken oder was?
Die sind fast wie Socken, nur die haben halt eine sehr weiche, aber ich sage jetzt mal stichsichere Sohle. Du kannst gefahrlos überall drüber laufen, aber du merkst ja jedes kleine Steinchen.
Genau.
Das ist einfach so eine Gummifläche. Und das ist angenehm, mit Gummiflächen an den Füßen zu haben? Also von innen ist ja noch eine Stoffschicht drüber. Also man läuft sozusagen Socke auf Socke. Ich würde sie auch nicht ohne Socken anziehen, weil es ist ja auch... Man kann sie auch waschen in der Waschmaschine, ist halt aufwendig. Aber du bist auf jeden Fall näher dran am Boden. Du merkst relativ zügig, dass es für den Fuß Arbeit ist, zu laufen. Also du merkst einfach Füße, schon Druckstellen und so. Es wird nicht verteilt. Und du merkst eben diesen Untergrund einfach. Also du merkst wirklich gerade, worauf du gehst. Du gehst nicht einfach drüber hinweg, sondern es macht einen Unterschied. Und das finde ich irgendwie nicht schlecht. Ich kann es empfehlen.
Wir gehen nach Duisburg zur Seidenstraße, die endet dort. Duisburg ist der Hafen, der extrem wichtig ist für diese Verbindung, für die eiserne Seidenstraße. Es gibt einen Artikel dazu in Brand 1. Verfasst hat ihn Sarah Sommer. Diese Strecke hat 11.000 Kilometer, ist eine der längsten Güterzugstrecken der Welt. Seit 2011 verbindet sie die im Südwesten Chinas gelegener Stadt Chongqing und deren Binnenhafen am Fluss Yangtze auf direktem Weg mit dem am Rhein gelegenen Hafen im Ruhrgebiet. In Chongqing kommen Waren aus dem ganzen Land an und werden in Containern auf Zügen verladen. Nach etwa zwölf Tagen erreichen die Züge Duisburg und die Waren werden weiter verteilt per Schiff über den Rhein, über Güterzüge und Lastwagen. Nun aber könnte man sagen, es ist doch toll. 2011 gab es dann auch einen Rekord zu verzeichnen. 2021 gab es einen Rekord zu verzeichnen. So viele Züge und Container wie noch nie waren über die eiserne Seidenstraße abgewickelt worden. Insgesamt mehr als 2.800 Fahrten. Das heißt dann, dass es durchschnittlich so 60 An- und Abfahrten pro Woche gibt. Manchmal sind es dann auch 70. Eigentlich wollte man auch die Zahl der abgefertigten Züge jetzt steigern. Man wollte es schaffen, dass 100 abgefertigt werden pro Woche. Doch heißt es hier, der russische Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine machte einen Strich durch die Rechnung. Die Zugverbindung nach China war gestört, denn die Strecke führt unter anderem durch Kasachstan, Russland und Belarus. Und nun stellt sich die Frage, können die Duisburger jetzt da einpacken? Also man muss es sich natürlich umstrukturieren. Russische Firmen können ihren Teil der Strecke weiterhin betreiben, im Übrigen, weil sie zwar wegen der europäischen Sanktionen von westlichen Kapitalmärkten abgeschnitten sind, aber nicht den Betrieb einstellen müssen. Aber im Vergleich zum Vorjahr sind jetzt diese Strecke nur noch um 60 Prozent ausgelastet. Und jetzt versucht man natürlich Alternativen aufzutun. Zum Beispiel könnte man über andere Lieferketten ja nachdenken. Türkei, welche Länder sind da eigentlich noch so dazwischen, die man stärker anvisieren könnte. Auch beim Hafenbetreiber heißt es DuSport. Macht man jetzt Erfahrungen? Wir sind es in der Logistik ja durchaus gewöhnt, dass es immer irgendwo hakt, sagt Kevin Gründer. Schließlich seien die globalen Lieferketten extrem komplex und eng getaktet, aber zur Zeit hakt es einfach an viel zu vielen Stellen. Und deshalb will man diese Verbindung schaffen. Carsten Hinne, der jetzt Vorstand dieser Hafengesellschaft ist, sagt, dass man jetzt so arbeiten muss, und das ist auch das, was man schon aus den vergangenen Jahren gelernt hat, dass man immer Ausweichrouten braucht. DuSport heißt es dann hier in dem Text hat daher unter anderem in Hafenanlagen und Terminals in Istanbul und Triest investiert. Der Seehafen von Rotterdam soll eine größere Rolle spielen und Hinde sagt, außerdem planen wir eine Südroute über Land und See aufzubauen, die Russland umgeht. Und das Ganze ist auch zu verstehen wieder als Teil dieses Industriepolitik-Programms, über das wir schon gesprochen haben, also die EU mit ihrem Global Connectivity-Programm, das also gewisserweise auch so ein Build Back Better Programm ist. Also diese, und es gibt ja auch diese Initiative, die Build Back Better World Initiative. Das heißt, man will da versuchen, Handel neu zu regeln. Also man kann sich nicht mehr auf das gerade laufende Geschäftsmodell verlassen. Und hier sieht man jetzt so im Kleinen, was da sich eigentlich tut. Also diese DuSport-Gruppe macht immerhin einen Umsatz von knapp 350 Millionen Euro. Investitionen 1 Milliarde Euro seit 98. Und hat 1600 Mitarbeiter. Und da geschieht also jetzt relativ viel, wie man Handelswege anders organisieren kann. Also dieses ganze Brandeins-Heft, das Aktuelle, ist der Logistik gewidmet. Naherliegend, eigentlich schon seit Corona naheliegend. Und hier setzt man sich jetzt mit verschiedenen einzelnen Aspekten auseinander.
Sehr gut. Ich finde eh immer gut diese Hinweise auf, wie geht es Russland gerade wirklich ökonomisch und auch China. Denn dieses Abfeiern von, und ja, sind natürlich krasse Zahlen, hohen Energiepreisen, die dann Russland gerade sehr zu Gute kommen. Aber was können sie kaufen mit Dollar? Und bei China eben auch. Also was nützt es ihnen in China diese Art der Machtverfestigung, wenn das Wirtschaftswachstum nicht da ist, und jetzt trotzdem hundert Millionen Menschen da irgendwie an Hunger, weil kein Reis in der Ernte. Und trotzdem baut man so viele Kohlekraftwerke, also wirklich in hunderte Gigawatt-Stile, wenn man jetzt Kohlekraftwerke nochmal aufzieht. Und alles nur noch über so eine Corona-App zu organisieren, scheint ja auch schwierig. Da fehlt irgendwie immer so ein realistischer Blick. Und da finde ich es sehr gut. Ich habe auch gerade gesehen, du hast ja die Brandeis in Original mit. Es ist ein sehr gutes Cover. Warum fehlt inzwischen immer etwas? Und dann hat man einfach ein paar Buchstaben. Okay, ich habe es vorhin schon angemerkt. Sehr viel mehr, als ich vorhin schon sagte, gibt es kaum zu sagen. Aber Goethe. Nicht Goethes Werk, sondern Goethe als Person. Sofern, soweit man sich ernähren kann, in einem Text dargelegt. In dem Falle nicht Goethe hat geschrieben, sondern es wurde über Goethe geschrieben, aber aus Erlebnis mit Goethe, denn es geht um Gespräche mit Goethe.
Goethe hat immer erzählt, was er für die Nachwelt erhalten wird, hielt.
Genau, also Johann Peter Eckermann, wir sind in Deutschland verwöhnt. Wir verstehen Deutsch, wir können das alles lesen. Die Welt konnte es nicht lesen. Es gab natürlich viele Übersetzungen von diesen sehr vertrauten Gesprächen. Ich habe noch mal nachgelesen, Eckermann spielt in einer langen Zeit der letzten Jahre Goethe eine große Rolle. Zum Glück konnte das dokumentiert werden. Es ist jetzt neu übersetzt auf Englisch, sodass auch die englisch sprechende Kompensatoren- schaft hier außer sich ist. Es ist der Economist, der darüber schreibt, deswegen ist der Text nicht besonders lang.
Aber ungewöhnlich, dass der Economist darüber schreibt, oder?
Genau, man weiß jetzt sogar nicht, wer schreibt eigentlich im Economist. Aber gut, der Economist hat ja auch noch mal die Autoren, die darüber Auskunft geben können. Und wie oben angemerkt, man zitiert kurz aus dem Forward, dass der Richie Robertson, wer auch immer das ist, hier meint, das ist einfach ein schönes Bild. Wir haben es hier mit einem tollen Painting zu tun, wo ja eine Fotografie nicht zur Verfügung steht, aufgrund von keiner Audio-Technik, um solche Gespräche zu dokumentieren. Aber alle haben sich Mühe gegeben, es nochmal ordentlich zu übersetzen. Und es ist auch so ein bisschen Kulturexport jetzt in die englisch sprechende Welt, denn Goethe damals in seinen Gesprächen nochmal, er bewundert die Natur und alles, was aus dem Ausland nach Deutschland kommt. Er reiste ja sowieso viel auch ins Ausland. Und hier hat man nochmal als Export aus Deutschland die deutsche Hinwendung ins Ausland und die Wahrnehmung der Natur. Also wir haben es ja nochmal mit einem guten Kulturexport zu tun, wie ja eh gerade schon, denn Rammstein in Amerika und so. Die englisch sprechende Welt kriegt jetzt nochmal das schöne und auch ein sehr überidealisiertes Bild von unserem Goethe. Und wird dann auch nochmal, wie es hier steht, die Anglophonen-Leser können sich dann nochmal, also können Goethe nochmal neu kennenlernen und nochmal nachvollziehen, warum er in Deutschland immer noch auf so hohem Sockel steht. Und ich finde, das ist eine sehr gute Nachricht, denn wir haben sehr viele deutsche Texte, die leider nicht ordentlich für die Welt zur Verfügung stehen, weil beispielsweise Rechtsstreitigkeiten immer noch dazu führen, dass man es einfach nicht übersetzt. Also viel Soziologie und so ein Kram. Aber zumindest der Goethe konnte hier mal befreit werden wieder und steht jetzt zur Verfügung.
Sehr gut. Und hier höre ich aber, wenn ich da noch gerade einhaken darf, dass aus manchen Schulplänen der Faust gestrichen werden soll. Das ist ja fatal, wenn das wirklich stattfindet. Also das ist so unglaublich. Und vor allen Dingen, man weiß ja schon, was für einen Ersatz da kommen wird. Es wird grauenhaft werden. Ich weiß auch nie, was diese Lehrer, Kultusminister und wer dann da jeweils zuständig ist, irgendwelche germanistischen Funktionäre, da reitet. Also dass sie dann noch glauben, jetzt müssen wir mal irgendwas modernisieren. Und das ist eigentlich auch identitätspolitisches Ding. Ich muss immer wieder auf den Böhmen zurückkommen. Es ist so dieses, naja gut, aber jetzt heute junge Leute, so im Tiktok-Zeitalter, was kann denn der Goethe ihnen da sagen und hat dann der Faust was mit mir zu tun? Find es mal heraus, ob das was mit dir zu tun hat. Die Antwort ist aber, kann ich schon vorwegnehmen, ja. Und das ist so fatal, wenn man einfach sagt, wir untergraben das alles. Denn was man nicht vergessen darf, ist, wir haben dieses dreiklitrige Schulsystem. Das finde ich auch nicht gut. Aber trotzdem hat so ein Unterricht grundsätzlich eine ganz große integrative Kraft. Wenn man nicht aus einem Bildungshaushalt kommt und nicht mal der Vater Goethe-Gedichte zitiert oder sonst was, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit sehr groß, dass man, wenn man es in der Schule nicht auch einmal erfährt, dann nicht richtig rankommt. Das kann dann nur noch über einen Freundeskreis oder so passieren. Wenn das in der Schule nicht passiert, dann ist der Weg für immer dorthin verschlossen. Und das ist so fatal. Klar, es müssen immer noch gute Lehrer und so weiter sein. Aber wenn das nicht da ist, also für mich war gerade der Schulunterricht, auch wenn ich gar nicht so tolle Deutschlehrer hatte, war doch ganz entscheidend in meiner literarischen Prägung. Einfach weil sich für mich davon dann vieles abgeleitet hat, dem ich danach gegangen bin. Der Unterricht kann eh nur Anreize geben, der kann nicht eine Vollabdeckung für den Literaturkanon liefern.
Ja, während du es sagtest und du kennst mich als Kindl-Buchleser.
Ja, da sehe ich jetzt hier noch Reklam-Bände in deinen Händen.
Also den Faust 1 habe ich, wusste ich, ich wusste auch, wo er steht, aber dass ich ihn zweimal habe, wusste ich nicht, aber ich habe ihn zweimal, ich kann meine beiden Hände mit Faust füllen. Und ich kann sagen, was mich damals so beeindruckt hat, man hat in der Schule ja häufiger damit zu tun, dass man selber mal was schreiben muss. Und man weiß, ja, schreiben ist ja wichtig, weil ich muss ja später Bewerbung schreiben. Dann macht man natürlich noch so verschiedene Übungen, die einem später nicht abverlangt werden. Man schreibt auch mal ein Vers oder so. Und diese Lehre daraus, schreibt mal zwei Strophengedicht. Und sie müssen sich reimen. Und dann sitzt man so eine halbe Stunde da und denkt, ich hätte jetzt was, aber es gefällt mir nicht. Und dann braucht man noch mal zwei Stunden. Und dann nimmt man es mit der Hausaufgabe. Und man braucht ewig, bis man zufrieden ist. Und dann nimmt man dieses Buch in die Hand und stellt fest, das reimmt sich. Und zwar auf Seite 9. Und auf Seite 37 reimmt es sich immer noch. Und auf Seite 81 reimmt es sich immer noch. Und dann geht man so durch, ach, auch auf Seite 100 reimmt es sich noch. Also eigentlich steckt hier die Lehre drin, auch wenn man es nicht liest, sondern nur mal kurz durchblättert. Mit Text ist alles möglich. Wenn man eine Bewerbung schreibt, ist in der Bewerbung alles möglich. Man ist durch nichts limitiert, denn man hat genau die gleichen Buchstaben wie der Goethe auch. Und dann limitiert man sich nur selber.
Das ist auch Universalismus, wenn man so möchte.
Genau. Und diese Lehre, für die muss man aber einmal ein Buch in die Hand nehmen, das einen wirklich krass durch allein dieses ist, reimt sich. Und egal, wo man reinspringt, das ist immer ein durchgetakteter Reim und so weiter. Allein das muss einen dann so beeindrucken.
Im Unterricht muss, im Deutschunterricht muss Frau's bleiben. Genauso muss im englischen Unterricht auch was von Shakespeare gelesen werden. Das geht überhaupt nicht anders. Richtig. Nun kommen wir zu einem Text noch ganz kurz, ein Interview mit der Professorin für internationale Wirtschaft an der TUM School of Management der Technischen Universität München. Sie heißt Dalia Marin, kannte ich nicht, wird hier zu Lieferketten interviewt. Wir sparen uns jetzt mal diese ganzen Kleinigkeiten. Chinas Aufstieg sagt sie noch mal, ist keinem anderen Land so zu gut gekommen wie Deutschland. Es wird für sie auch nicht so leicht nachvollziehbar, wie man da sich ganz rauslösen kann. Das ist jedenfalls nicht so einfach wie mit Russland. Nun wird sie gefragt, ob man die Globalisierung auf so einem Rückwärtsgang erlebt. Und da sagt sie, meines Erachtens ist das gar keine Frage. Schon vor dem Ukraine-Krieg war offensichtlich, dass wir es mit einem Rückzug in der Globalisierung zu tun haben. Der Offenheitsgrad der Weltwirtschaft, das sind die Exporte plus Importe in Prozent des Proto-Sozialprodukts, ist seit der Finanzkrise um 15 Prozent gesunken. Wir waren ja auch gar nicht so bewusst, dass wir da eine Deglobalisierung in gewisser Weise erleben. Wir haben natürlich das Problem beim Transport, dass auch da Arbeitskräfte fehlen. Und Unternehmen stellen eigentlich auch ganz gerne Roboter ein, statt Menschen. Aber das ist dann auch die Frage, lohnt es sich? Was kostet das Ganze? Sie geht davon aus, dass wir eine Tendenz zur Rückverlagung weiter haben. Wir wissen aus einer Erfahrung des IFO-Instituts, dass 19 Prozent der deutschen Firmen rückverlagern wollen, also 19 Prozent. Davon planen sieben Prozent nicht zu einem deutschen Zulieferer, sondern direkt ins Unternehmen zurückzuverlagern. Also alles wieder unter einem Dach zu haben. Sie glaubt, dass der Staat da gar nicht viel machen muss, weil Unternehmen machen eines immer, nämlich Risikobewertung. Das ist das A und O. Da müsste der Staat nichts tun, um das in irgendeiner Weise zu unterstützen. Sondern die sagen schon, na gut, wenn da die Hirte fängt, was machen wir eigentlich? Das ist genau das, was betriebswirtschaftliches Denken tatsächlich ausmacht. Und da würde ich auch ihr zustimmen wollen. Mein Problem, und deswegen habe ich es jetzt hier mitgebracht, ist eher was anderes. Und zwar heißt es da nochmal, die Regierung ist gut beraten, eine Liste essenzieller Güter zu machen, die Deutschland aus China, aber auch aus anderen Autokratien und sogar befreundeten Ländern bezieht, um die Abhängigkeit von einzelnen Ländern auf jeden Fall zu vermeiden. Es gibt ja nicht nur geopolitische Risiken, sondern vor allem auch Umweltrisiken, die in der Zukunft zunehmen werden. Wenn es zum Ausfall kommt, muss es einen Plan B, C, D geben. Das ist wie bei einem Aktiendepot. Wie viel Risiko, Sicherheit und Gewinn will man haben. Alles richtig noch. Das haben wir zum Beispiel bei den Masken ja gesehen. Und jetzt kommt die entscheidende Frage. Bedeutet das in Zukunft weniger Gewinn für uns? Denn natürlich ist, wenn wir outsourcen können, wenn wir günstige Lieferwege haben, ist das sehr volkswirtschaftlich lukrativ. Und da sagt sie ja, aber Sicherheit ist ein wichtigeres Gut geworden. Und das muss uns einige Prozente des Wachstums wert sein. Das heißt, wenn wir diese Umstrukturierung jetzt erleben, die Deglobalisierung und die Sicherung der Lieferwege, dann kostet das Wachstum. Und dann wird nochmal nachgefragt, das heißt, wir werden ärmer. Dann sagt sie ja, wir werden ärmer. Die Frage ist nicht, ob, sondern wie viel. Und hier kann ich gar nicht ihr widersprechen, nur da liegt für mich eigentlich jetzt etwas drin, was uns alarmieren sollte. Wir haben jetzt seit der Finanzkrise 2008 erlebt, zwar ein bisschen Deglobalisierung, aber eigentlich lief es für die Weltwirtschaft prima, für Deutschland lief es prima. Es ist so, dass sich die Anzahl der Milliardäre jährlich vervielfach verdoppeln zumindest. Und trotzdem haben wir keine Umverteilung erlebt. Wir haben eine Zuspitzung am Wohnungsmarkt erlebt. Wir haben keine Erhöhung von Löhnen radikal erlebt und viele andere Dinge, die ich aufzählen könnte. Und das war in einer Blütezeit. Also wir hatten jetzt eine Blütezeit. Bis Corona kam hatten wir eine Blütezeit. Und eigentlich auch noch während Corona hatten wir eine Blütezeit. Und jetzt wird alles teurer. Jetzt bekommen wir hier gesagt, naja, das kostet auch Wachstum. Und wenn es dann heißt, ja, wir werden ärmer, dann ist die Frage, wer wird ärmer? Und was wir jetzt gerade erleben, ist tatsächlich, dass die, die jetzt ganz viel sich angehäuft haben, sich treffen und mal beratschlagen, was machen wir, wenn die Welt untergeht? Aber wir müssen diesen Satz, wir werden ärmer, wirklich so begreifen, dass das bedeuten würde, nicht Volkswirtschaft, sondern Menschen werden weniger Geld zum Leben haben. Und wenn die Politik so bleibt, wie sie jetzt ist, dann bedeutet das wirklich mit Wir werden ärmer, dass 50, 60, vielleicht sogar 70 Prozent der Menschen ärmer werden, was aber nicht irgendwie so, was heißt, wir leben bescheidener, sondern da kommen existenzielle Ängste, ganz viele neue Belastungen, ganz viel neuer Druck auf sehr viele Menschen zu. Und da würde ich erstmal nochmal gerne die Frage der Deklopalisierung neu diskutieren, inwieweit wir jetzt plötzlich auf dem Trip sind, wir machen uns von allen möglichen Dingen los, weil uns das jetzt aus irgendwelchen Gründen, scheinbar Universalistische, die dann doch keine Universalistischen sind, nicht mehr recht ist. Also da müssen wir nochmal fragen, können wir da nur mit den besten Freunden zusammen agieren? Und wenn wir das mit Ja beantworten, dann müssen wir aber tatsächlich dann für die, die schon die ganze Zeit auch nicht profitiert haben, zeigen, dass die nicht ärmer werden. Also wenn dieser Wir werden ärmer Satz, der dürfte nur bezogen sein auf diejenigen, die in den letzten zehn Jahren nur profitiert haben. Dann bin ich sehr dafür, dass die was ärmer werden. Und am Ende schafft man es auch noch, wenn man nur drei S-Klassen zu Hause stehen hat. Aber wenn das bedeutet, jetzt reist euch mal zusammen. Und wir hatten diese ganzen Verzichtsauffrufe und all das schon. Ihr werdet jetzt mehr ärmer, aber wir denken auch mal in der Zeit über den Bunker nach. Oder wir werden weiterhin auch den großen Tesla fahren. Dann ist das falsch. Und ich glaube, hier in diesem Satz, wir werden ärmer, liegt eigentlich das drin, was jetzt politisch zu tun wäre. Nämlich, dass die, die ohnehin arm sind, oder die, die auch bescheiden leben oder einen einigermaßen Wohlstand haben, dass die auf keinen Fall ärmer werden dürfen.
Es ist im Großen noch so eine Diskussion. Ich habe das im Buch, kriege jetzt die Zahlen nicht genau zusammen, aber wir haben die letzten 10, 20, 30 Jahre irgendwann so eine BIP-Verdoppelung in Deutschland. In der Zeit ist aber das Lohnniveau nur um 17% oder so gestiegen. Also der Lohn schleppt sich ganz schön, also dieses Triple Down funktioniert ganz schön schlecht. Der Lohn hängt, nachdem es eh seit 68 abgekoppelt wurde in die 86. Also man beginnt in Amerika diese Reconomics und plötzlich stellt man in Deutschland fest, ja, Wirtschaftswachstum ist ganz gut, Lohnquote sinkt entsprechend, also diese Verkopplung, dass es eins zu eins hochging, Wirtschaftswachstum, Wirtschaftswunder usw. hört dann auf. Und dann stellt sich ja die ganz große Frage, ja, aber wenn jetzt das ganze Niveau sinkt, weil, und das kennen wir ja, durch Bevölkerungsgröße, Wirtschaftsgröße definiert wird, was passiert denn dann eigentlich mit den Löhnen? Also wenn man schon so viel volkswirtschaftliches, allgemeine Wachstum braucht, um so ein bisschen Lohnzuwachs zu erwirtschaften oder übrig zu lassen, und wir bleiben bei diesem Gefüge, dann heißt ja, okay, die nächsten 20 Jahre Wirtschaftsschrumpfung, allein durch das jedes Jahr 300.000, 400.000 weniger Menschen arbeiten, dass ja die Löhne wirklich abstürzen müssen.
Genau, und das betrifft die Mitte der Gesellschaft, weil wir spüren hier nicht eine Reine-Hartz-Vier-Debatte, sondern es ist Mitte der Gesellschaft, und das hat ja jetzt auch schon jeder gespürt, der, weiß ich nicht, das Reihenhaus hat und zwei Kinder und muss eine andere Energierechnung jetzt zahlen. Oder wir sehen es ja auch bei jenen, die dann in diesen dollen Jahren 2012, 2013, 2014 ein Kredit aufgenommen haben, ein Hauskredit, zehn Jahre Zinsbindung hatten. Die wird dann aufgehoben nach zehn Jahren, und dann wird neu verhandelt. Und wenn man jetzt bei 3,6 Prozent oder so steht, dann kostet das einfach zwischen 50.000 und 80.000 Euro, also kommt auf die Kreditsumme natürlich an, mehr Geld. Also einfach nur, weil die EZB gesagt hat, jetzt drehen wir mal hoch, das wird schon gegen die Inflation helfen. Und natürlich hilft das in einer gewissen Weise, wenn man eine Rezession produziert, dass dann irgendwann auch die Inflation aufhört. Aber es ist fatal. Und deswegen sind all diese Sachen, wir müssen uns daran gewöhnen, ärmer zu werden. Wo ich sagen würde, ja, mir fallen Leute ein, die sich daran gewöhnen müssten. Aber das sind andere.
Genau. Aber die Diskussionen laufen wie sie laufen. Wir sehen es schon.
Wir werden es verfolgen. Es wird, also es wird, glaube ich, relativ bitter. Wir wollen nicht verzagen. Wir wollen noch sagen, dass wir schon diesmal wissen, was wir das nächste Mal lesen, mit Spannung von ganzen Medien in Deutschland erwartet. Und wir werden, wir haben es gesagt, nur den Text, nur die Argumente uns ansehen und nicht, wer hat wann mal wo und wer hat die schönste Frisur von beiden. Wir sprechen mit anderen Worten über das Buch von Harald Wälzer und Richard David Precht.
Es ist angekündigt für den 29. September, was ja dann heißt, wir haben eine Woche Zeit, das zu lesen.
Genau.
Und dann können wir es im Salon besprechen, im Oktober.
Bis dahin einen schönen Monat.